Die zweite Bundesliga der Männer, sie bleibt einfach interessant. Der HSV verliert in Paderborn, Lautern und Magdeburg gerade auf Rang 2 und 3. Da kenn ich einige, die würden sagen, ja, nehm ich als Aufsteiger. Und auch unten drin passiert wieder so einiges. Wie gut, dass wieder Ligaturzeit ist und wir jetzt hier gleich darüber sprechen. Aber nicht ich, sondern Eva Lottabohle wird natürlich wieder moderieren. Und dann legen wir heute Schwerpunkte auf Darmstadt 98 mit Matthias Kneifel und auf Hannover 96 mit Max Boxer. Freue mich schon sehr auf die Sendung. Ich werde gleich wieder verschwinden. Warum mache ich dann dieses Intro? Es gibt wichtige Neuigkeiten, die den Rasenfunk betreffen und die muss ich euch an dieser Stelle mitteilen. Und zwar werden wir dazu gezwungen, unsere Kontoverbindung zu verändern. Details dazu werden wir vielleicht mal irgendwann in einem Tribüngespräch erklären. Wichtig für euch zu wissen ist, wir haben einen relativ kurzen Zeitraum, in dem ihr dann euren Dauerauftrag auf das neue Konto umstellen müsst. Noch wissen wir noch nicht die neue E-Bahn, aber wir würden euch bitten, registriert euch doch bitte schon mal als Supporterinnen und Supporter, wenn ihr uns unterstützt oder unterstützen wollt. Denn dann landet ihr auf dem News-Verteiler, den wir dann eben verwenden können, sobald wir alle Infos dazu haben. Ihr werdet nicht zugespämmt, keine Sorge. In der Regel bekommt ihr eine bis zwei E-Mails, geht einfach auf rasenfunk.de und dann im Menü kann man sich als Supporter in registrieren. Und wie gesagt, es passiert nichts anderes, als dass wir einfach eure Mail-Adresse bekommen. Ihr könnt auch anklicken, ob ihr dann nach dem Zufallsprinzip hier erwähnt werden wollt in den Sendungen. Das kennt ihr ja hoffentlich schon. Und vor allem bekommt ihr aber dann von uns Mitte März, wahrscheinlich irgendwann ab dem 19. März von uns eine E-Mail mit allen Infos. Und dann haben wir einen begrenzten Zeitraum, in dem ihr euren Dauerauftrag bitte endet. Und dann wird das hoffentlich für uns finanziell nicht zu schlimm, denn wir hatten ja schon mal einen Bankwechsel und da haben wir festgestellt, trotz aller Bemühungen, da bleiben dann doch einige Supporterbeiträge auf der Strecke. Wir hoffen, diesmal wird es besser. Es wird noch viel mehr Informationen dazu geben. Ich werde das jetzt auch in allen Sendungen ab jetzt sagen. Deswegen beginne ich hier diese Sendung, obwohl ich sie gar nicht moderiere. In diesem Sinne danke für euren Support und jetzt aber viel Spaß mit der Liga Tour. Ich bin raus. Eva, take it away. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rosti zu kurz ab, der lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1-0. Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Lieben. So, hier bin ich da noch wieder. Ich bin Eva Lottabohle und übernehme hier nach Max Intro einfach ganz frech wieder. Ein kleiner Hinweis noch mal, ein Thread oder der Link zu einem Thread im Rasenfunk-Forum. Den findet ihr schon mal in den Show Notes für mehr Infos noch zu der ganzen Thematik rund um diese Kontosache. Aber jetzt kommen wir wirklich mal zum Sportlichen und ich warte wirklich auf den Moment, dass die zweite Ligamann-Award dafür bekommt, dass sie den unlogischsten Plot aller Zeiten verfolgen, jede Saison wieder, weil, meine Güte, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, es könnte kein Drehbuchautor jemals so schreiben. Aber ich freue mich wirklich sehr, dass ich mit zwei ganz wundervollen Gästen über die zweite Liga sprechen darf. Bevor ich euch aber die beiden vorstelle, wie immer der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch eure Spenden, deshalb sitze ich hier beispielsweise und eben auch diese beiden Gäste. Und der Dank geht heute stellvertretend an Levin, Friedrich, Domaniak und Magdalena. Vielen Dank, dass ihr Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen seid. Und dran denken, ab 19. März die E-Mails checken. So, jetzt darf ich aber die anderen beiden Menschen in dieser Runde neben mir vorstellen. Zum einen ist zum ersten Mal dabei Max Brogsa, er ist Teil des Vorwärts nach weit Podcasts. Hallo Max und Grüße nach Niedersachsen.
Ja, hallo Eva, grüße zurück nach Bielefeld und ich bin sehr froh über die Einladung gewesen nach Empfehlung von Marc, auch Grüße an Marc. Und ja, es wäre schön gewesen, wenn die Situation bei uns ja so ruhig gewesen wäre, wie ich mir das erhofft hätte, weil sportlich haben wir den Aufstieg abgeschrieben gehabt und man hätte ja nicht wissen können, dass der EV sich plötzlich in einem Streit mit der Kapitalzettel befindet und wir plötzlich eine Lizenzgefährdung für die nächste Saison in der zweiten Bundesliga haben.
Ja, stay tuned, darüber reden wir gleich auf jeden Fall. Und dann darf ich, ich sag's jetzt einfach mal so, meine Lieblingsstimme für Darmstadt 98 hier im Rasenfunk begrüßen. Er war zuletzt im September hier. Matthias Kneife betreibt unter anderem den Kick-Schuh-Blog und schreibt die SVD-Kolumne unter Pappeln. Und ich weiß, euer Podcast ruht gerade etwas, aber dass wir hier vorwärts, nach weit und hoch und weit als Podcast vertreten haben, das musste ich leider einmal, musste ich hier einmal nennen. Das ist einfach eine schöne Geschichte. Also Long Story Short, Hallo Matthias, schön, dass du da bist.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Blumen. Servus und hallo zusammen. Ich freue mich auch hier dabei zu sein und muss mir eigentlich schon eine Popcorn-Tüte holen, weil ich glaube, hier gibt es wirklich viel über Hannover zu berichten, was so ein bisschen fernab des Sportplatzes zu tun hat. Aber ich bin ganz oah und mach nachher dann noch ein paar Takes zu den Lydien.
Bevor wir jetzt aber gleich schauen, was eben bei Hannover und Darmstadt so auf und neben dem Platz los ist, wollen wir wie gewohnt einen Blick auf die Lage der Liga werfen. Und Matthias, ich weiß, du hast dich sehr damit beschäftigt. Was ist denn für dich vor allem nach diesem Wochenende so das spannendste Thema?
Ja, da gibt es einige, aber voranstellen möchte ich dann schon, dass wir es einfach mit einem Wettbewerb zu tun haben. Das, was man in der ersten Liga in Teilen durchaus abspricht, das haben wir hier zum wiederholten Male. Das hat ja deine Einführung auch so ein bisschen angedeutet. Und das kann man ja nur gutheißen, wenn sich quasi jede Mannschaft noch in irgendeiner Art und Weise mit irgendwas beschäftigen muss. Also nach oben hin mit dem Aufstieg nach unten hin. Doch leider auch die Linien vielleicht ein bisschen noch mit dem Abstiegskampf. Und insofern also vier Punkte zwischen 1 und 8 zwischen den beiden HSVs. Dieser Liga ist schon der Wahnsinn, weil es sich meines Erachtens ja fast vor drei Spieltagen schon so ein bisschen getrennt hat. Vorneweg Köln HSV und Lautern, die da doch drei bis vier Punkte zwischen sich und die Verfolger gelegt hatten. Aber jetzt ist es schon wieder zusammen gerückt. Und wenn man nach unten guckt, finde ich stehen zwar die Neulinge unten drin. Drei Plätze, sprich Ulln, Regensburg und Münster. 15, 17 und 18, aber das ist trotzdem, Regensburg vielleicht ein bisschen, aber die anderen beiden nicht außer Konkurrenz, sondern schon noch in Schlagdistance und überzeugend durch eine stabile Defensive. Und auch mehr Spiele nicht verloren, als verloren. Da sind natürlich ein paar Unentschieden zu viel dabei, um vielleicht sich unten weg zu bewegen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, da muss man schon den Hut ziehen, dass sie sich da doch ganz ordentlich schlagen, würde ich mal sagen. Das war es zum Thema Wettbewerb. Den finde ich, der ist gegeben. Und zum anderen würde ich den Fokus ein bisschen auf den Südwesten legen. Da gibt es zwei Teams, die sich auch kräftig in den Aufstiegskampf einmischen, nämlich Elbersberg und Kaiserslautern. Und Elbersberg hat ja auch mal so eine kleinere Durststrecke, aber hat sich jetzt wieder massiv zurückgemeldet. Und es ist wirklich beeindruckend, muss ich sagen, was dieser Club leistet, auch wenn er einen Geldgeber in der Hinterhand hat. Aber es ist dennoch eine Mannschaft der eher namenlosen. Und ich hatte zuletzt mit Luca Marseilla ein Gespräch hier bei den Ligien, der vor der Saison von Viktoria Köln gekommen ist aus der dritten Liga. Der hatte quasi Elbersberg jetzt mit den Ligien erlebt, aber auch schon zu Drittliga-Zeiten. Und er sprach davon, dass es einfach eine Basis ist, die da über Jahre hinwegelegt wurde. Also viele Spieler sind noch an Bord. Ich habe mich da gestern noch mal kurz rückversichert. Also Fellhauer, Sikinger, Schahin, Schnellbacher, die sind schon seit Jahren seit der Regionalliga dabei und spielen heute noch eine Rolle. Hinzu kommen junge Spieler, die vor der Saison vielleicht nicht jedem was sagten, aber inzwischen nachhaltig. Aslani oder auch Damar und Baum, die von Zweitvertretungen gekommen sind, aber sehr, sehr auf sich aufmerksam machen. Das heißt, da wird eigentlich durchweg eine gute Arbeit geleistet und wir Ligien haben das schmerzhaft zu spüren bekommen, indem wir 3-0 und 4-0 weggefiedelt wurden und beide Male wirklich chancenlos waren. Also das heißt, die spielen jetzt gar nicht so ein Außenseiterfußball, sondern die können wirklich mit dem Ball umgehen, die haben die Ligien sehr gut ausgeguckt, haben eine gute Positionierung, sammeln die zweiten Bälle ein, wirken manchmal wie ein Mann mehr auf dem Feld und wäre in Nürnberger nicht auf die Idee gekommen, sich nachhaltig aus dem Hettelwerb zu knallen, dann wärs auch über 90 Minuten so gewesen. Ja, also da kann man echt nur den Hut ziehen, was die da leisten und wie gesagt jetzt wieder Schlagdistance zu oben und um auch noch keines Lautern rein zu holen, da kennen wir ja in Darmstadt den Markus Anfang und der war hier nicht durchweg beliebt, war natürlich jetzt auch damals noch eher so die Corona-Phase, wo man sich nicht so durchweg ein Bild von einem Trainer machen konnte, aber er hat sich durchaus so ein bisschen starkköpfig damals präsentiert, wollte einen mutigen Fußball spielen, auch einen nach vorne gerichteten Fußball, aber irgendwie hat er die Balance über zwei Drittel der Saison gar nicht hingekriegt, also wir standen da schon mit dem Rücken zur Wand und seine Entlassung war durchaus nicht so weit weg, aber dann hat er umgestellt, hat sich so ein bisschen doch besonnen, was die Mannschaft eigentlich kann, hat auf eine Doppel-Sechs umgestellt, war da sehr viel stabiler in der Defensive und nicht mehr so toranfällig, gegentoranfällig wie zuvor und dann ging es in die richtige Richtung. Er hat aber damals auch schon gezeigt, dass er Spieler weiterentwickeln kann, also ich denke gerade Honsack oder auch Melem und Skake haben unter ihm sicherlich einen Schritt nach vorne getan und jetzt zeigt er in Kaiserslautern, dass er mit einem Team, das ja jetzt vor einem Jahr eher noch dem Abstieg gegenüber stand, Gutes leisten kann. Die haben sich natürlich auch gut verstärkt und ich denke die Winterneuzugänge zeigen, da ist was dabei am Schopfe ergriffen zu werden. Das ist nicht irgendwie, wir haben mal gucken vielleicht, also gerade wenn man zwei Augsburg-Spiele holt, Bauer und Breithaupt, dann ist das nicht so verkehrt. Selbst wenn man Tomiak nach Hannover abgegeben hat, aber das ist auch irgendwie so mit dem Pokalerfolg glaube ich, da haben die Fans nachhaltig auf sich aufmerksam gemacht mit der Choreo, so nach dem Motto hier ist ein Statement, wir sind wieder da und dieses Jahr fahren sie es konsequent bislang. Also auch da Chapeau kann man nur den Hut davor ziehen, was da sich in den letzten Monaten entwickelt hat.
Ja, ich empfehle da auf jeden Fall auch nochmal die vergangenen Ligatour-Schwerpunkte über den 1. FC Kaiserslautern und eben auch über die SV Elbersberg, also auch wenn die zum Teil, also gerade bei Elbersberg auch ein bisschen länger zurückliegen, aber passt trotzdem, was da auch gerade über Horst Steffen viel gesagt wird, der eben ja der Trainer da ist und sie haben ja jetzt auch gerade am Wochenende auch wieder 4-0 gegen Hertha gewonnen. Max, was ist dir noch aufgefallen?
Ja, also was ich anschließend zu Matthias noch sagen kann, dass ich diesen Wettbewerb in der zweiten Bundesliga so verrückt finde, weil wir haben eigentlich nur Momentaufnahmen, weil wir sprechen vor Beginn der Rückrunde davon, dass Köln und Hamburg fast sichere Aufsteiger sind und die sich ja mit der Dominanz und der Kaderstärke ja vorne absetzen müssen und Köln dann drei Spielländer dann nicht gewinnt und Hamburg gegen ja auswärts quasi die klaren Schwächen wieder aufweist. Und irgendwie ist es immer so, also jetzt auch Kaiserslautern als Beispiel, die haben jetzt gegen die ganzen Abschiebskalendaren und die unteren Vereine super gespielt und auch wirklich dominante Siege erzielt. Aber jetzt kommen ja Gegner wie Elbersberg, Paderborn, Düsseldorf und Magdeburg und die können dann ganz plötzlich wieder im Mittelfeld sein. Also ich finde, dass dieser Charakter der zweiten Bundesliga vor allem in diesem Jahr unfassbar außergewöhnlich ist, weil wir nicht wie in der Vergangenheit immer so klare dominante Aufstiegsfavoriten haben.
Ja, definitiv.
Man sieht es ja auch an Elbersberg, die just nicht gegen die Kellerkinder gut aussahen, gegen die drei Aufsteiger haben sie bislang viermal gespielt und nur zwei Punkte geholt. Also hätten sie da konsequent weitergepunktet, wie sie es gegen die starken Teams machen, dann wären die jetzt schon Erster, könnte man fast Schluss folgern. Also die haben eine gewisse Konstanz außer gegen die schwächeren Teams. Aber du hast recht, das ist bei Kaislautern jetzt so ein bisschen die Wochen der Wahrheit, die auf sie zukommen.
Ja, und es ist also generell finde ich, also irgendwie hat man immer so das Gefühl, es gibt jetzt ein Team, wo man dann sagt, okay, jetzt die werden sich dann bis zum Ende festsetzen. So wie wir es schon über Köln gesagt haben, die sind jetzt, also ich finde es in der Tabellenkonstellation immer schwierig zu sagen, sie sind abgerutscht, weil es liegen ja nicht so wahnsinnig viele Punkte, nämlich genau einer zwischen Platz eins und fünf. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem erstmal so, man guckt dann irgendwie drauf und denkt so, okay, was ist da jetzt passiert? Aber und ich weiß, also Leute, die das Format regelmäßig hören, können es wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr hören, aber es ist halt Serienaufbau, ne? Also und zwar in beide Richtungen. Das spielt halt die größte Rolle. Das ist einfach so. So wenn du einmal dieses Momentum auf deiner Seite hast, kannst du da auch mal rausrutschen und klar, es bleibt natürlich eng. Aber ja, also ich habe bei bei Hamburg-Fans mal ein bisschen quer gelesen. Sie waren nach der Paderborn-Niederlage schon deutlich angefressen, weil sie gesagt haben, naja, es sind halt immer diese Spiele, die wir nicht gewinnen können. Ich meine, sie haben ja das Spiel gegen Köln beispielsweise gewonnen. Aber dass da halt zum Beispiel auch dieses 2-2 gegen Hannover dabei war und so, also dass man schon ab und zu eben gegen diese Mit-Ausstiegskonkurrenten dann jetzt eben die die Federn lässt. Und das ist natürlich ja nicht, also gerade wenn du sie halt von ihr weghalten willst, nicht gerade produktiv. Aber generell also crazy, auf jeden Fall was da passiert, auch gerade bei der Hertha. Also die sind komplett weiter in der Krise, also auch unter Neutriner Leitel bisher kein Sieg, nur ein Sieg in der Rückrunde, null zu viel eben gegen Elversberg. Da stand schon, das war schon der Halbzeitstand und das war wirklich brutal. Also was ich so von Hertha-Fans gehört hab, die werfen der Mannschaft glaube ich auch nicht vollkommen zu Unrecht, zu einer gewissen Arroganz vor, wie man da eben in Elversberg auftreten wollte. Da ist auch viel Diskussion bei und da gibt's viele Probleme. Dann natürlich auch die Empfehlung, mal in Marks Hertha-Base-Podcast rein zu hören. Die nehmen da das Spiel auch ganz gut auseinander. Aber ja, sie haben eben auch nur 4 Punkte Vorsprung auf den 16. Da eben haben wir auch schon drüber gesprochen, gut Braunschweig. Dieses 1-1 gegen Ulm war phasenweise nicht gerade das schönste Fußballspiel für Ulm. Natürlich bitter, weil sie jetzt glaube ich 3-4 mal kein schlechtes Spiel machen, aber am Ende entweder verlieren, weil es auch irgendwie eine random rote Karte entlang gibt oder halt eben dieses Ergebnis nicht über die Zeit bringen können. Und es ist natürlich enorm bitter, dass man dann eben gegen einen Mitabschiegskonkurrenten es nicht schafft, diesen wichtigen 3er einzufahren und Braunschalke somit eben auch diese Distanz wahren kann. Aber ja, auch zum Beispiel Münster super bitter gegen Schalke. Loris Karyos ist zurück im Tor, ich glaube nach zwei Jahren oder so mal wieder. Und das war eine sehr, sehr gute Leistung für ihn, das muss man schon mal sagen. Ist natürlich der Klassiker, dann werden solche Torhüter auch gerne mal, kriegen sehr, sehr viel Medienzeit. Aber ja, also es war auch wirklich eine gute Leistung. Münster tat mir da fast schon immer leid. Und wenn ich das sage, weiß man, das dauert ein bisschen, bis ich das sage. Aber ja, also es wird auf jeden Fall nicht, nicht spannend, glaube ich.
Also was ich beim Thema Hertha so spannend finde, ist eigentlich, dass das ja eine Mannschaft ist, wenn ich mir den Kader anschaue, mit Vereinen, also durch Erstliga-Qualität, was die Spieler angeht. Also Marthorn Dada in den Linus Gächter, in den John John Kenny, das sind ja Spieler, die in der ersten Liga spielen könnten. Aber das Mannschaftsgefüge so zerstört ist scheinbar und es ist intern irgendwie so große Probleme gibt, dass eine Defensive, die so solide sein muss, eigentlich so krass versagt. Und ja auch offensiv, also mit Ibrahim Maaze und Fabian Reese und Derry Scherhan hast du ja Spieler, die sich auch ganz klar bei Aufstiegsfavoriten irgendwie empfehlen könnten mit ihren Leistungen.
Ja, das ist natürlich manchmal eben die Gefahr, wenn du zu viele Spieler hast, die vielleicht auch denken, sie könnten höher spielen. Also und ich glaube, das ist eben beispielsweise der Unterschied zu eben den Spielern, die auch Elbersberg scoutet. Wir haben es ja eben gesagt, Spieler, die eben schon lange da sind oder halt eben auch welche von Zweitvertretungen. Das natürlich holst du dir einfach ganz andere Spieler ins Team. Und also auch das tut mir leid, dass ich da immer den Vergleich ziehen muss, aber ich kenn es halt auch aus Spielefelder-Zeiten so. Dann spielt da halt irgendwie Robin Hakunko und die denken halt, ja, okay, wir gehören eigentlich. Letztes Jahr Bundesliga gespielt, waren ja einer der wichtigsten Spieler und konnten im Sommer nicht raus aus dem Vertrag oder was auch immer und das zerstört dann einfach so ein Gefüge ohne den einzelnen Spielern dann da ihm was Böses zu wollen. Aber es hilft natürlich dann auch nicht, dass ein Toni-Leistner da nur auf die jungen Spieler jetzt drauf drückt. So ich glaube nicht, dass das der richtige Weg ist, wie du aus dieser Krise halt auch rauskommst. Aber es zeigt natürlich auch, also es lag sicherlich auch in Teilen am Trainer, aber es ist halt, ich glaube, diese, ja die Wurzel des Problems, die ist einfach viel viel tiefer und wenn Hertha da nicht aufpasst, dann wird das richtig, richtig übel. Also auch Hertha-Fans tun mir einfach wirklich nur noch leid. Also da geht es ja auch seit fünf, sechs Jahren auch einfach nur partiell immer weiter bergab. Es gab eben dieses Hoch mit Kai Behrstein als Präsidenten, wo eben viele Hertha-Fans sagen, so das war eigentlich dieser positive Moment in den letzten Jahren und jetzt bist du eigentlich aber, also gerade ist glaube ich alles schlimm für die und ich kann es auch, also ich kann es auch echt nachvollziehen, weil du ja irgendwann, dir fehlen halt diese Erfolgserlebnisse als Fan. Also wirklich diese dauerhafte.
Ja, gut.
Genau und Leitl hat es ja auch am Wochenende gesagt, dass der Blick muss nach unten gehen. Das heißt jetzt Abschiedskampf, da darf niemand irgendwo mit Gedanken ganz woanders sein, sondern darum geht's und das fand ich schon richtig. Natürlich nach so einer Klatsche erst recht, die man in Elvis Berg einkassiert hat. Aber an ihm lag es jetzt mutmaßlich oder am Vorgänger nicht so sehr. Leitl ist jetzt mit zwei Niederlagen gestartet. Ja, ein Selbstläufer sieht anders aus, also deshalb nicht beneidenswert, erst mal in so einem Schlamassel zu stecken, sich doch irgendwo im Bewusstsein anderswo zu verorten, als jetzt in der Realität angekommen zu sein. Das sind meistens nicht so gute Zusammenhaltungen.
Ich glaube es war Garten 0-0 gegen Nürnberg, oder? Ich glaube es war eine Niederlage.
Ja, es war ein okes 0-0, aber es war auch nichts.
Genau, aber dann waren es keine zwei Niederlagen, mit denen er gestartet hat, sondern ein Energy und eine Niederlage.
Ich weiß falsch, abgespeichert. Bevor es Meldung gibt, was ist hier los, sagen wir mal zweimal mit 0 Toren.
Ja, genau.
Das trifft schon, 0-4 Tordifferenz insgesamt in zwei Spielen.
Das passt, ich wollte es nur einmal korrigieren wissen. Gut, aber dann lass uns doch einmal auf den ersten Schwerpunktverein gucken, auf Hannover 96. Es ist Platz 8, das sind 38 Punkte, 31 zu 24 Tore, 10 Siege, 8 Unentschieden und 6 Niederlagen, man ist punktgleich mit Fortuna Düsseldorf, die stehen auf Platz 7. Und seit der Winterpause ist Andre Breitenreiter der neue Trainer. Es gab einen Sieg jetzt am Wochenende gegen Nürnberg, der erste Sieg nach fünf unentschiedenen Folgen. Ich glaube, manche Auswärtsfans konnten es gar nicht richtig glauben. Und es ist aber auch eben erst der zweite Sieg in der Rückrunde gewesen. Max, wie siehst du denn momentan Hannover's Chancen? Ich frage einfach mal direkt auf den Ausstieg. Also was denkst du, was ist da noch drin?
Ja, also ich bin natürlich kurz im Auswärtsstil. Ich bin Vielfahrer eigentlich und Nürnberg war das erste Spiel, was ich mal verpassen wollte, weil ich mir dachte, ja gut, okay, zeitlich schwer und so. Und dann wurde ich natürlich mit dem Auswärtssieg bestraft, aber Spaß beiseite. Also zum Thema Ausstieg, es ist ein sehr, sehr heiß diskutiertes Thema, weil natürlich im Rahmen des Dreijahresplan durch Sportdirektor Markus Mann klar war, dass das diese Saison wird, wo wir aufsteigen wollen. Und das hat ja jetzt bis zum Winter mit Stefan Leithel nicht geklappt, der dann auch folgerichtig entlassen wurde. Und das große Problem ist dann auch gewesen, dass wir ja erst mal nicht wussten, was für eine Alternative kommt nach Leithel. Welcher Trainer kann denn verpflichtet werden? Der Trainermarkt wurde sondiert und da kamen nach einer halben Stunde, glaube ich, circa nach der Meldung, dass Leithel entlassen wurde, die ersten Presseberichte von den Lokalpressen, das andere beiden Reiter übernimmt. Und das hat dann natürlich die Situation in Hannover so ein bisschen abgekühlt. Und man dachte sich so, ja, was, wenn es noch schlechter wird als mit Leithel? Und die aktuelle Punkteausbeute oder der Abstand nach oben ist ja eben weniger als mit Leithel. Aber man muss sich natürlich veranschaulichen, was dazu geführt hat. Also wir spielen deutlich attraktiveren Fußball als unter Leithel. Wir spielen deutlich offensiveren Fußball. Wir sind deutlich mehr in der Lage, Torschance zu kreieren. Und die vergangenen Ergebnisse spiegeln nicht ganz so wieder, wie wir auf dem Platz spielen. Also das Spiel gegen Münster musstest du gewinnen. Das war ein absoluter Pflichtzieg, weil du da sehr dominant agiert hast, weil du da sehr hoch agiert hast, weil du damit sehr viel Druck agiert hast. Und dann eben durch einen Umschaltmoment die Rechtsverteidigung vernachlässigt. Gegen Hamburg hast du dich gerettet, gegen Düsseldorf musstest du ebenfalls gewinnen. Vor allem, weil wir gegen eine Mannschaft gespielt haben, ohne Mittelfeld, also Isaac Johannesson und Haag sind ja gelbgesperrt gewesen. Auf dem Metzenberg, wo ich gewesen bin, hatte ich mit einer der verrücktesten Fußballpartien, die ich gesehen habe, weil ich dachte, also das kann ja nicht sein, also 2-0-3, die musst du ja eigentlich führen bei den hundertprozentigen Torschancen, die ich da vor meinen Augen gesehen habe. Gegen ein paar der Bornen wurdest du völlig an die Wand gespielt, muss ich so sagen, also das war die schwächste Partie der Saison, fast so schwach wie unser Auswärtsspiel in Elbersberg damals noch. Und gegen Nürnberg hast du wieder gut gespielt. Das heißt also die Gesamtbilanz ist eigentlich, die meisten Partien, die du gewinnen musst, schaffst du es nicht zu gewinnen und du müsstest ja eigentlich viel mehr Punkte erarbeiten als du hast. Jetzt natürlich die Frage, ob das am Trainer liegt und ja, der Gesamtkonsens bei uns, das auch im Podcast und auch in der Bubble ist es, dass auch der Kader insgesamt nicht ausreicht. Also für mir uns ist der Aufstieg ist abgehakt, weil es einfach mindestens drei Vereine gibt in der Liga, die besser gearbeitet haben als wir, weil fehlende Positionen nicht geschlossen wurden, weil unzurechene Transfers erzielt wurden, weil die Kaderplanung um vorhinein nicht so, also zum Beispiel Tresoldi und St.Glantkamp wurden jeweils mindestens 15 Tore zugeschrieben, vielleicht auch nur von einem und Tresoldi steht bei sechs Toren und Jessic steht bei vier Toren. Also es ist deutlich zu wenig für einen Aufsteiger. Und wir hoffen jetzt, dass wir durch die guten Leistungen, ich meine, wir sind immer noch ungeschlagen, glaube ich seit acht Spielen jetzt, wenn man jetzt noch das Herterspiel aus der Hinrunde mitnimmt. Also wir hoffen nicht, wir versuchen wirklich sehr, sehr passiv zu bleiben, aber also für mich persönlich ist der Aufstieg nicht etwas, worauf ich jetzt noch poche.
Einmal um die Thematik mit dem Stürmerproblem oder generell mit dem Offensivproblem zu untermalen. Also Hannover hat definitiv schon mal die schlechteste Offensive in dieser Aufstiegsrunde, streng genommen sogar in den Top 15. Also nur Münster, Braunschweig, Ulm und Regensburg haben weniger Tore geschossen als Hannover 96 und also laut XG underperformt man da auch um acht Tore. Ja, das ist bei ungefähr bei 39. Also werden wir uns schon mal ein bisschen weiter oben, aber dafür hat man eben die beste Defensive in der Liga. Also nur 24 Gegentore in 24 Spielen, da brauche ich euch den Schnitt nicht ausrechnen. Das kriegt ja alle selber hin und da overperformt man aber quasi. Also da hätte man neun mehr kassieren müssen, aber man hat eben neun Spiele zu null, gibt es eben für Zieler. Also nur Elversberg mit mehr zu null Spielen, habe ich auch erst nicht geglaubt, aber das ist eben auch einer deren Schlüssel zum Erfolg. Und dann hast du es eben. Also dein drittbester Torschütze ist Marcel Heizenberg mit drei Toren. So das ist halt, das reicht nicht. So also klar, wenn du irgendwie wirklich eine gute Verteilung hast, aber das ist es, also dafür sind sechs Tore als bester Torschütze, hast du eben schon gesagt, das ist einfach viel zu wenig. Gleichzeitig hast du eben auch immer die gleichen Namen, die dann eben auch in den Top-Score an. Also Tresoldi auch acht, acht Scorer-Punkte, ein Gang kam, sieben Scorer-Punkte, danach hast du dann Leopold, der ja zumindest sehr ansehnlich mit einem Freischuss getroffen hat gegen Nürnberg, aber zum Beispiel einen Harald Nielsen, also eigentlich so mehr oder weniger immer mal so ein Mr. Reliable da vorne drin, der hat ein Tor in 22 Spielen geschossen.
Der ist auch lange immer so im Zenit gekommen. Was mich halt auch stört, ist, dass man ja, also die Probleme sind ja für alle ersichtlich gewesen offensiv und das Problem ist ja auch, wenn wir jetzt rückblickend mal auf alle Aufsteiger gucken in den letzten Jahren, ist, dass jeder Aufsteiger mindestens ein bis zwei Topmänner hatte, ob das jetzt Heidenheim mit dem Kleinen jetzt oder Janiklas Beste war, ob das jetzt Kiel mit Imen Skripski war, der glaube ich 13, 14 Tore hatte, ob das Schalke mit Terodde oder auch Bielefeld damals mit Fabian Kloss gewesen ist und das ist einfach was uns fehlt und dagegen können wir nicht ankämpfen, weil im Endeffekt gewinnen die Tore die Spiele. Wenn du vorne die Tore nicht machst, dann brauchst du auch nicht darüber sprechen, dass du in die Bundesliga gehörst.
Ja und dann meinst du dann auch, da wurde, also klar, Wintertransfers ist immer so eine Sache, weil es natürlich sehr, sehr viel schwieriger ist, Wintertransfers in eben ein Team zu integrieren, als es mit Sommertransfers halt der Fall ist. Man hat dann im Winter Rabi Matondo als Laie geholt, irgendwie dann noch Boris Tomiak aus Kaiserslautern, also irgendwie auch schon ein erfahrener Spieler und dann eben noch für die Innenverteidigung und für die Außenverteidigungsbeispieler. Ich fand gerade Matondo, also hab ich auch irgendwie quer gelesen, wird natürlich so ein bisschen gehypt, aber ich also fand ich auch fast so ein bisschen so ein Okay, wir holen uns jetzt einen Namentransfer, kann sicherlich auch ein super spannender Spieler werden, aber ich hab ja nicht, ich hab bei Hannover jetzt nicht so das Gefühl, dass die, also dass da irgendwie wie ein Spieleröffner fehlt oder ein schneller Spieler, also hat man meiner Meinung nach ja zum Beispiel auch mit Mumulu, der da irgendwie immer ganz gut mal was reinbringen kann oder so. Aber es fehlt ja ehrlich gesagt einfach, also es klingt immer so doof, aber so ein Brecher vorne drin, der dann einfach mal und der vielleicht nicht Marcel Halzenberg ist, der dann irgendwie den verkappten Stürmer hinwangen geben muss, sondern halt einfach ganz schlicht einen Neuner, der trifft und das fehlt Hannover ja oder siehst du das auch?
Ja, also ich finde es auch, persönlich finde ich es in der Kaderplanung fahrlässig, deinen Sturm darauf auszulegen, dass du ein 20-jähriges Talent hast mit Tresoldi, der zwar ein Potenzial hat sehr, sehr hoch zu spielen und für mich der beste U21-deutsche Stürmer ist aktuell und mit Jessica einen gar keinen Spieler hast, der aktuell sehr schwierigen Stand hat. Also Jessica ist ja eigentlich verletzungsanfällig und war ja in jeder Station der Vergangenheit längerfristig verletzt und ich finde es einfach zu fahrlässig dann mit Havard Nielsen, Andreas Vogelsommer dahinter, damit zu rechnen, dass dieser Sturm vorne ausreicht. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das dann eben von Markus Mann und dem Team falsch bewertet wurde oder ob man einfach gehofft hat, das sollte sich so weit entwickelt und das kannst du in der Aufstiegsaison nicht machen. Zum Thema Rabé Matondo ist, ich war in meinem Bericht damals zu ihm recht ambivalent. Also ich natürlich hatte klare Qualitäten im Tempo und im 1 gegen 1, das hat er ja auch in seiner ersten Einwechslung gezeigt, aber er ist jetzt zum Beispiel am Knie verletzt und das Knie ist immer bei ihm so eine Geschichte gewesen, die immer sehr, sehr schwierig gewesen ist. Und da sprechen wir ja im Wintertransfer-Fans dann nur mit Boris Tomiak als klare Verstärkung. Und wenn du dann von den Gesellschaftern noch hörst, medial, dass wir bereit sind, großflächig zu investieren und den Aufstieg zu sichern und das dann das Resultat ist, dann ist das auch als Fan ganz klar enttäuschend.
Ja und vor allem also an der Stelle will ich No Offens an Andreas Vogelsammer oder auch Havan Ilsen, aber es ist Colts, also so ein bisschen die 90er, 20er Saison hat angerufen und will eben ihre Top-Spieler zurück. Also ich meine Vogelsammer kann immer ein Unterschiedspieler sein, wenn er möchte, aber eigentlich braucht er meistens halt so ein neuner halt vorne mit drin, weil er ist es halt nicht, also meiner Meinung nach.
Doch bei allem Respekt an Andreas Vogelsammer und Havann Nielsen, aber es fehlt ja wirklich an Qualität. Also das sind ja keine Fähigkeiten im Dribbling, mangelnde Fähigkeiten im Passspiel, mangelnde Fähigkeiten im Abschluss als Mittelstürmer. Also das ist ja, darauf kannst du ja nicht bauen. Das ist ja nicht die Bank, die du als Einwächs-, als Aussteigstange da haben möchtest, wenn du Spiele einwechseln willst. Also wenn ich mir angucke, was Hamburg da von der Bank bringen kann oder Köln, das ist ja Weltenunterschiedung vielleicht zu uns.
Naja und weil du halt, also es ist halt so ärgerlich, weil du ja eben das Fundament mit der guten Defensive hast. Also das ist ja wirklich, Hannover ist ja irgendwie nicht eine Schießbude der Liga oder so, sondern eben das absolute Gegenteil und das ist dann halt bitter. Also es ist halt, wenn du endlich das hast und dann...
Ja, bitter triffts gut und auch, also Königstransfer in Anführungszeichen mal gesagt. Janik Rochelt ist es ja der teuerste Neuzugang in den letzten fünf Jahren gewesen, seit Marvin Duxch und man hätte ja, Gerüchten zufolge war ja letztes Jahr, also letzten Sommer war man in der Equal-Termane dran, für anderthalb Millionen für den gleichen Preis, aber da hat man es nicht geschafft, die Gesellschaft davon zu überzeugen, dass man das Geld investieren kann. Und dann ist Rochelt halt so eine Sache gewesen. Ich hab vorher schon in meinem Bericht dazu gesagt, dass er eine klare Sofortverstärkung sein kann, aber das Profil, was er erfüllt hat, ist meiner Meinung nach nicht das gewesen, was man abdenken hätte müssen. Und so war es auch nicht ohne Grund, dass Rochelt auch in ganz Deutschland, bis auf St. Pauli eigentlich keinerlei Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat von Vereinen, weil für den Preis ist es einfach zu teuer gewesen, seine Aufstiegs-Software in Spieler zu setzen, der nicht so höher oder relevanter als in Elbersberg gespielt hat. Weil der Druck ist ja hier deutlich größer. Man hat ihm das auch angemerkt, dass ihm ganz klar Selbstbewusstsein gefehlt hat am Anfang, dass er sich gar nicht getraut hat und dass er sich jetzt mit dem Trainerwechsel zwar geändert hat. Und er steht jetzt glaube ich bei drei Scorer in der Rückrunde und er kommt langsam rein, aber es ist eben nicht das, was du für einen Aufstieg brauchst. Du brauchst klare Leute mit Selbstbewusstsein, die die Fähigkeit haben, Spiele von alleine zu verändern, wie das in Davieselke bei Hamburg ist und wie das eben in der Vergangenheit auch andere Spieler gewesen sind.
Also ich vermute in Volte Made war wahrscheinlich eher Wunschdenken, weil wer bei einem Champions League Club landet, da hätte Hannover sich glaube ich gewaltig strecken müssen.
Ich korrigiere dich kurz, das war letzten Sommer noch. Der ist ja diesen Sommer ablösefrei gegangen und letzten Sommer, als er dann ein Jahr bei Bremen glaube ich war, nachdem er bei Elversburg wiedergekommen ist, da war eben das Angebot da. Und jetzt ist er ja auch verständlicherweise in Stuttgart. Der ist ja ablösefrei gegangen und auch völlig berechtigterweise so eine ganz klare Qualität und spielt nicht ohne Grund in der Champions League.
Genau. Ja, ich finde es halt, also keine Ahnung, ich finde bei Hannover ist es fast wie bei keinem Verein so, dass du eigentlich so das Gefühl hast, diese Saisons gehen einfach in eine, also diese drei Saisons gehen in eine lange Saison über. So weil man irgendwie immer, also am Ende fehlt es immer an einer Stelle und am Ende muss man irgendwie immer auch mal einen Blick auf den Kaderplaner werfen. Und ja, also Markus Mann, ich meine wir werden gleich noch in, ach es ist fehlig über ihn zu sprechen, hat sicherlich keine schlechte Arbeit gemacht, aber man muss ja auch einfach sagen, es ist halt, es sind halt nicht die Unterschiedstransfers gewesen. Also man kann ja auch fast mal fragen, also so blöd wie es klingt, aber warum beispielsweise nicht Davy Selke vor dem HSV genommen, beispielsweise. Also ob ich jetzt also von den Ausstiegsaspirationen zu Hannover oder zu Hamburg gehe, muss im Endeffekt egal sein, aber das ist natürlich auch so ein Ding, wen habe ich eben noch im Kader und da passt Selke halt dann zum HSV dann gut ist immer leichter zu sagen, dass er da besser reingepasst hat jetzt, da war einfach von einfach vielleicht auch von den restlichen Spielern um ihn herum. Trotz halt auch Trainerwechsel am Ende besser rein.
War denn der Trainerwechsel alternativlos? Also war der sozusagen unumkehrbar, weil wenn ich richtig mich entzünde, dann wäre die dritte Saison ja noch im Gange, die zum Aufstieg führen sollte. Und ihr wart ja jetzt nicht irgendwie total aus dem Rennen. Also mich hat es doch ein bisschen überrascht, aber eben nur als Außenstehender und nicht als Fan von Hannover. Aber dennoch schien es ja an der Zeit gewesen zu sein.
Ja, also aus der Perspektive betrachtet, wenn wir jetzt den Stand nach dem Herterspiel nehmen, war der Trainerwechsel folgerichtig. Und das hat mehrere Gründe und das sind vor allem taktische Gründe gewesen, also fußballerische Gründe, weil gegen den Ball waren wir immer gut ausgerichtet. Also viel Variation mit hohem und intensiven Pressing, tiefer Block gegen Magdeburg, mal gegen Köln, um die Siege oder Unentschieden zu halten. Aber das größte Problem war eigentlich in zweieinhalb Jahren Entwicklung, dass wir mit dem Ball immer noch so waren wie vorher. Also fehlende Torchancen. Wir hatten nicht ein Umschalttor nach zweieinhalb Jahren nach Ballgewinn. Die Raumbesetzung war katastrophal teilweise in Spielen, wo du ein Tor erzielen musst. Das Konzept war, also es war so einseitig, wir hatten gegen Preußen Münster teilweise 25 Flanken in einem 0-0 im Auswärtsspiel, weil wir nicht in der Lage gekommen sind, gegen so einen tiefen Block zu spielen. Das hat sich ja über Jahre hinweg gezogen. Wir haben Auswärtsspieler in Wiesbaden verloren oder unentschieden gespielt, gegen Osternbrück auswärts verloren, eben genau durch solche Probleme. Und also ein System, was eigentlich im Ballbesitz nicht dominant sein soll, sondern durch Umschaltmomente agieren soll, das haben die halt nicht hinbekommen. Und Markus Mann hat sich ohne Grund dann nach dem Pokal aus gegen Bielefeld als Angsthasenfußball beschrieben. Weil du hast ja wirklich angemerkt, dass die Spieler durch die Mentalität, durch die Einstellung, die der Trainer ihnen mitgegeben hat, Angst hatten, Risiko einzugehen. Und das ist eben das Problem. Du musst ja Mut zum Tor haben, wenn du Spiele gewinnen möchtest. Also für mich war und auch intern, also es gibt halt auch, gab halt interne Differenzen und so und auch Unzufriedenheit, wie es denn weitergeht, wenn man nicht aufsteigt und so. Deswegen war der Trainerwechsel schon folgerichtig. Bei der Nachfolge kann man jetzt natürlich diskutieren, weil das ja schlechter geworden ist. Aber er war unumgänglich. Also man musste wechseln. Man musste wechseln.
Weil, also korrigiere mich, wenn ich falsch liege, aber man hat Leitel doch auf Platz 6 entlassen und steht jetzt auf Platz 8. Ist das richtig?
Ja, das ist richtig. Also wir sind ja auch, ich glaube wir sind punktetechnisch glaube ich genauso weit entfernt. Ich kann mal ganz schnell nachgucken, aber ich glaube wir sind, am 17. Spieltag sind wir ja vier Punkte entfernt gewesen. Also wir haben keinerlei Unterschiede zum Platz 1. Aber ja, es ist trotzdem richtig gewesen. Und ich würde den Trainerwechsel auch wieder machen und ich hätte ihn auch früher gemacht. Wir haben nämlich nach dem 3-0-Auslösungsanlage gegen Elbersberg auch schon darüber im Podcast diskutiert. Und für uns war es auch klar, dass Leitel hier nicht weitermachen kann und auch, es hat aber nicht mehr gepasst. Und manchmal muss man eben den Weg gehen, dass man sich für einen neuen Trainer entscheidet. Und Breitenreiter war nicht meine Wunschlösung und Breitenreiter war auch jemand, bei dem man gesagt hat, ja eigentlich ist es ja nichts Besseres als Leitel. Jetzt spielt es bei besseren Fußball. Der Ergebnisse bleiben aus und es lässt sich halt auf den Kader zurückführen. Dann also man hätte den Trainer gar nicht wechseln müssen, weil es wäre das Gleiche bei rausgekommen, sind wir der Meinung, vor allem im Kontext des Kaders. Aber ja, das musste passieren.
Also siehst du da schon am Ende, also kann ich schon ein bisschen lesen. Es ist dann doch irgendwie in einer Weise auch eben Kritik an Markus Mann. Also gar nicht mal, dass man eben eine Trainerentlassung gemacht hat, aber eventuell der Zeitpunkt, also dass es einfach fast zu spät war. Also meinst du sogar im Sinne zu spät von, es hätte schon im Sommer passieren können, weil man da eben keine, also über zwei Jahre lang keine klare Verbesserung gesehen hat?
Ja, es eben, also man hat ja, Markus Mann hat ja nicht ohne Grund so früh nach dem Pokal aus dem Bielefeld schon gesagt, dass er sich diesen Angsthaus im Fußball nicht länger anschauen will. Also da war auf jeden Fall schon so ein bisschen die Frage, haben wir die richtigen Entscheidungen gemacht, mit Leitl weiterzumachen? Ja, jetzt kommt aber ein spannender Punkt, weil ich habe die These und viele andere, dass die Trainerentlassung zwar von Markus Mann initiiert wurde, aber die Einschläge von Andre Breitenreiter dann durch Martin Kindt erfolgt ist. Also quasi, dass das gar nicht der Wunsch von Markus Mann gewesen sei, Andre Breitenreiter einzustellen, sondern eben, weil Andre Breitenreiter wieder den Kontakt zu Martin Kindt gesucht hat und dann auch gemeinsam im NDR aufgetreten sind bei dieser Sendung für Kinder. Also das ist so ein bisschen Aluhut Theorie aus der Hannover-Ecke, aber es wäre auf jeden Fall logisch, weil das halt so von Martin Kindt nicht untypisch gewesen wäre, seinen eigenen Willen dadurch zu setzen.
Also ich find's halt wirklich, ja wir sagen Aluhut, aber wir sehen ja auch, also ich werde nie aus meinem Gedächtnis streichen können, dass da auf einmal irgendwann wieder Mirko Slomka an der Seitenlinie stand bei Hannover 96. Also das war, ich glaube das war auch 1920 die Saison und das war eins der, also das war eine ganz wilde Zeit. Aber das, also ich hab das hier auch schon ganz häufig gesagt, ich finde halt dieses Trainer-Karussell in der zweiten Liga sowieso noch mal problematischer als in der Bundesliga, einfach weil man ja doch dann irgendwie nicht so das aus dem ganz hohen Regal rausgreifen kann und dann guckst du halt ach, wer war denn schon mal hier und so. Und also wirklich keinerlei auch Respektlosigkeit an andere Breitenreiter, aber es hat also mich als Anova-Fan überhaupt nicht angezündet, dass der dann da wieder an der Seitenlinie steht. Und das ist halt schon was in der Kombination mit den Transfers, die wir eben schon angesprochen haben, die dann eben schon irgendwie, also am Ende ist Markus Mann klar, ob da jetzt Martin Kindh hinter sitzt oder nicht, ist was anderes, aber die eben man auf Markus Mann zurückführen müssen oder kann. Ja.
Ja, auch bei der Bewertung von Markus Mann Arbeit sind aktuell auch hitzige Diskussionen natürlich auch bei uns, bei Hannover. Weil natürlich die Fragestellung ist, ist das Ziel des Aufstiegs erreicht worden mit dem Kader? Und das ist ja am Ende dann nein. Das heißt, es hätte keinen Unterschied gemacht, ob jetzt Markus Mann oder Jörg Schmatke weiterhin der Sportdirektor hier gewesen wäre, weil das Ziel ja nicht erreicht wurde. Natürlich ist es ein bisschen simpel, darauf runterzubrechen. Da werden wir drauf blicken, was für ein Kader wir vor drei, vier Jahren hatten und was für Spieler hier gespielt haben und dass da Spieler über dem Zenit wie Mike Franz oder Dominik Heiser, die Doppel-Sechs besetzt haben, statt talentierte, aufsteigende Spieler wie Enzo Leopold oder auch mit Marius Verletz ein Spieler wiederkommt, von dem ich mir sehr, sehr viel erhoffe in Hannover und auch seine Qualität bei Bielefeld klar bewiesen hat. Also auch Verkäufe von Derrick Höhne für dreieinhalb Millionen nach ablösefreien Transfer, Brighter Rain B für sechs Millionen nach Portugal verkauft. Also immer wieder hohe Erlöse erzielt, die eben nicht investiert werden konnten durch die Position der Gesellschafter. Also er hat sein Bestes getan. Aber am Ende stehen halt vier Millionen Transferausgaben in vier Jahren da. Und das ist deutlich, deutlich zu wenig. Ich meine Hamburg und Köln haben allein diesen Winter jeweils sechseinhalb Millionen ausgegeben, um sich den Aufstieg zu sichern. Und das ist dann, dann bist du auch irgendwann finanziell nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig bei den anderen Vereinen.
Na gut, und Hannover 96 musste 200.000 Euro an der Minie Bielefeld überweisen, dafür, dass sie sich in einen Spieler zurückgeholt haben.
Ja, aber das ist okay. Das ist ja Ausbildungsvergütung, würde ich sagen. Und ich glaube, es war auch richtig im Sommer die Leidung noch mal zu machen, weil hätte ich hier auf jeden Fall keinen Stand bekommen. Also hätte in der zweiten Mannschaft spielen müssen. Und ich glaube, das Drittliga-Aufstiegskampf, ihm bei seinem Profil, also er ist ja Spieler, ist sehr aktiv und gestaltet das Spiel sehr gerne selber, ihm deutlich besser getan als eine zweite Mannschaft, die im Abstiegskampf ist, obwohl es immer diese ekligen, schwierigen, intensiven Spiele gibt und so, wo er sich nicht so gut präsentieren kann. Und ich glaube, dass sich das, die Anlage von 200.000 Euro für Bielefeld schon gelohnt hat für uns.
Gut, wir müssen jetzt tatsächlich, eigentlich wollten wir diesen sportlichen Tag gar nicht so lange halten, weil wir kommen jetzt zu einem, das ist meine Schuld, aber wir kommen jetzt zu einem, ja, einfach schönen, schönen Thema für einen Dienstagabend, an dem gefühlt in den letzten 24 Stunden nochmal richtig schön Fahrt reingekommen ist. Ich präsentiere das Thema Geschäftsführerproblematik. Ich fange einmal ganz kurz mit einem Intro an und dann würde ich ganz nett an Max übergeben, der da ein bisschen tiefer drin ist in der Materie und euch das bestimmt nochmal besser erklären kann. Aber so ein bisschen zu den Facts. Warum gibt es eine Geschäftsführerproblematik bei Hannover 96? Laut dem BGH-Urteil aus dem Juli 2024 war die Abberufung von Martin Kind als Chef der Hannover 96 Management GmbH durch den Mutterverein Hannover 96 e.V. Also schon mal, wenn ich gleich rede, werde ich immer so den, also wenn ich von Vereinsseite spreche, meine ich immer den e.V. und die Kapitalgesellschaft ist oder die Kapitalseite ist eben die Investorenseite. Also nur das schon mal. Wichtig, diese beiden Seiten schon mal zu kennen. Und also diese Abberufung war schon, ich glaube, ist glaube ich inzwischen zweieinhalb Jahre her ungefähr. Also das lag eben in der Vergangenheit und hat sich aber ewig lang gezogen. Also durch ziemlich viele Prozesse, dass es halt auch irgendwann eben bis zum BGH ging, also, Entschuldigung, zum Bundesgerichtshof. So und jetzt ist eben das Problem. Seit acht Monaten können sich die Seiten, also Kapital- und Vereinsseite, nicht auf einen beziehungsweise zwei neue Geschäftsführer einigen. Und das wird jetzt zum Problem, weil bis zum 17. März die Lizenzunterlagen bei der DFL eingereicht werden müssen. Und das vom vertretungsberechtigten Organ des Bewerbers. Und das ist eben bei Hannover 96 als Kapitalgesellschaft, also als GmbH und Co. KGH. Tut mir wirklich superleid. Aber eben der Geschäftsführer und Markus Mann als Sportdirektor erfüllt das als Prokurist eben nicht. Also Zusammenfassung, es braucht ein Geschäftsführer, um die Lizenzunterlagen für die zweite Liga, also für die nächste Saison bei der DFL einzureichen. Und diesen Geschäftsführer, den gibt es nicht. Und der wird bestimmt noch eine letzte Sache von dem Vierköpfigen Aufsichtsrat bzw. der Management GmbH. Und die besteht aus vier Personen. Wie gesagt, Kapitalseitig sind das Gregor Baum und Hauke Jagau. Bis Oktober war noch Martins Kins Sohn Matthias Kind, Teil des Aufsichtsrats. Und vereinsseitig sind es Sebastian Kramer und Ralf Nessler. So Max, was ist denn jetzt der Stand? Warum können sich denn diese Seiten nicht auf einen Geschäftsführer einigen?
Ja, also das Problem zwischen Verein, zwischen EV und der Kapitalseite ist ja bei uns schon gängig. Das war ja dann letztens ganz präsent beim DFL Investoren Deal, wo dann Martin Kind als letzte entscheidende Stimme nicht preisgegeben hat, was er denn getan hat, wie er sich denn entschieden hat. Und dadurch der EV der Meinung war, dass er nicht an Weisung des Vereins Folge geleistet hat. So und wie du beschrieben hast, besteht der Aufsichtsrat, ist paritätisch gestaltet, also zwei Vertreter des EV und zwei von der Kapitalseite und dementsprechend müssen die sich einigen. Und aktuell können sie sich nicht einigen, denn die Kapitalseite würde gerne Markus Mann zum Geschäftsführer Sportern nennen und sind auch bereit dazu gerne in Kombination mit einem Geschäftsführer Finanzen, wie das in anderen Fällen üblich ist. Der EV hat einen anderen Geschäftsführerkehrendaten vorgeschlagen, mit dem alle Parteien einverstanden werden. Der soll den Posten alleine übernehmen und vor allem aber, was viel entscheidender ist, also die Person, wer den Geschäftsführer Posten übernimmt, ist eigentlich gar nicht so wichtig. Aber vor allem soll diese Person dem EV gegenüber weisungsbefugt und auskunftsrechtlich sein. Und dagegen stellt sich die Kapitalseite ja eben quer, weil sie diese Weisungsklausel raus haben wollen, um den Einfluss weiterhin quasi beibehalten zu dürfen. Problem ist aber, der Mutterverein hat nach 50 plus 1 immer das Weisungsrecht und die Stimmmehrheit zu behalten, wenn der Profibereich wie bei uns eben in einer Kapitalgesellschaft ausgegliedert wurde. Und das ist auch in der Satzung des EV verankert gemäß §15 Absatz 3.i, dass 50 plus 1 immer Folge geleistet werden muss. Das heißt, um irgendwie diesem Konflikt aus dem Weg zu gehen, hat die Kapitalseite dann am 24. Februar den Weg zum Amtsgericht Hannover gemacht, einen Notgeschäftsführer beantragt. Und das wurde jetzt heute Mittag, heute Nachmittag abgelehnt, weil es ja nicht die Aufgabe des Amtsgerichtes, interne Streitigkeiten des Aufsichtsrat zu lösen. Das ist ja auch völlig richtig so. Also es ist ein bisschen absurd, dass die Kapitalseite dann den juristischen Weg geht, um sich da irgendwie durchzusetzen. Also heruntergebrochen heißt es ja eigentlich, die Kapitalseite möchte den EV dazu zwingen im Anschlungsvertrag des Geschäftsführers für die Management GmbH, die zu 100 Prozent dem EV gehört, einen Absatz zu streichen, der im Rahmen von 50 plus 1 zwingend notwendig ist und eingehalten werden muss, damit wir überhaupt die Lizenz bekommen dürfen. Weil wir dürfen ja, wenn wir gegen 50 plus 1 verstoßen, die Lizenz gar nicht erhalten. Dementsprechend bleibt dem EV und dem Verein gar keine andere Wahl, als diese Weisungsklausel mit einzubehalten. Und das ist der Kapitalseite ja nicht egal, aber ich glaube, dass da billigend in Kauf genommen wird, dass wir die Lizenz nicht bekommen, indem wir keinen Geschäftsführer einberufen. Und das ist ein großes Problem, weil sich ja dann, also dann steigen wir eben ab, wenn wir nicht in der zweiten Bundesliga ohne Lizenz bleiben dürfen.
Ja und dann gäbe es ja glaube ich also in der Theorie, ohne Geschäftsführer kann man auch keine Lizenz für die dritte Liga stellen. Und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dann müsste nicht nur dann quasi die U23 von Hannover zwangsabsteigen, sondern weil man dann ja eh in der Regionalliga spielen müsste oder so.
Kurzer Einwand, die Lizenzverfahren für die dritte Liga sind gestern bereits abgeschlossen worden. Das ist für die zweite Bundesliga, es ist der 17. März und für die dritte Liga war es glaube ich gestern. Das heißt, wir könnten gar nicht in die dritte Liga absteigen, sondern wir würden dann zwangsläufig in die Regionalliga absteigen.
Genau und dann müsste aber glaube ich auch trotzdem die U23 zwangsabsteigen. Ja, die müsste auch zwangsabsteigen. Ich hab auch irgendwann, also es ging ja, als damals es um diese ganze härte Thematik ging, hieß es dann glaube ich auch mal, dass dann, ich glaube dann die quasi die Profimannschaft wird dann quasi mit der U23 gleichgeschlossen.
Vielleicht wird sich die zweite Mannschaft auch auflösen, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die Gesellschafter und dass die Vereinsorte sich irgendwie einigen. Also ich hoffe einfach, dass die Kapitaltote bereit ist, sich dem DFL-Richtlinie und der 50 plus 1-Richtlinie klar zu orientieren, weil dem Verein bleibt, außer sie würden satzungsdurchbrechend handeln und gegen 50 plus 1 verstoßen, ja gar keine andere Wahl als diese Weisungsklausel mit 1 zu beziehen.
Ja und einfach nochmal, also zur Thematik Markus Mann, wir haben jetzt nämlich schon sehr viel über ihn gesprochen, der war am Wochenende dezent schlecht gelaunt, hat dann glaube ich am Sky-Mikro gesagt, dieser Zustand ist unerträglich, wenn wir so weitermachen, dann werden diese Personen sowohl den EV als auch die Profi-Abteilung gegen die Wand fahren. Und genau, er drohte sogar mit seinem Abschied nach dieser Saison. Irgendwann sei der Zeitpunkt erreicht, wo man den Zirkus nicht mehr mitmacht. Thema Zirkus, der Verein, der wiederum im Spiel ins Spiel gebracht wird, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist der KSC. Die haben ja nach dem Weggang von Oliver Kreuzer ist eben die Stelle wackant. Witziger Fun-Fact. Christian Eichner, also der Trainer von dem KSC, ist mit Manns Schwester liiert. Also das habt ihr bestimmt ja an dieser Stelle schon mal gehört. Es klingt inzwischen einfach nur noch wie eine RTL-Vorabendserie, aber es ist halt wirklich einfach, also Martin Kindert wiederum gesagt, also am wichtigsten sei für ihn, dass er Mann berufen wird, weil eben die Kapitalseite ihn als Sportdirektor bzw. als Geschäftsführer Sport vorgeschlagen hat. Und dann wird halt gesagt, er steht für die Entwicklung, für das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum und so weiter. Okay, also den Ausstieg hat er aber, naja, okay. Und er steht für das Produkt 96 und das ist der Sport. Also das finde ich auch schon ein sehr interessantes Wording. Und dann hat er noch gesagt über die Gedankenspiele, dass man eben eventuell den Club auch einfach verlassen könnte. Da sei er vollkommen überrascht gewesen, das zu lesen. Er hat bisher nie ein Signal gegeben. Also es ist halt wirklich wahnsinnig kompliziert, weil also wir haben das jetzt irgendwie so auch zum Teil ein bisschen humoristisch abgearbeitet, aber es geht also, die haben jetzt zwei Wochen Zeit, der die nächste, also der Amtsgericht hat das abgelehnt. Genau heute hat dann noch eben die Kapitalseite quasi ja den Einspruch erhoben und damit es jetzt beim Oberlandesgericht Zelle landet. Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass das Oberlandesgericht Zelle in was anderes sagt, auch gerade weil Martin Kindler meinte, ja die wissen ja alle, wie prekär unsere Lage ist und die müssen jetzt auch einfach mal schneller arbeiten, um uns das zu ermöglichen. Ich glaube nicht, dass das besonders gut kommt, vor allem weil, also wenn einmal gesagt wird, naja es sind interne Streitigkeiten und das wird eben auch dargelegt, warum das so ist, gehe ich nicht davon aus, dass das Oberlandesgericht jetzt sagt, hier ist euer Notgeschäftsführer. Also fällt mir schwer, dass ich das, also es müssen sich halt beide Seiten einigen. So das, ich glaube.
Warum sollte das Gericht sich auch darum kümmern? Das hat ja nichts, da ist ja gar keine juristische, irgendwie gar kein juristisches Interesse daran, sich da irgendwie um den Aufsichtsrat zu kümmern. Kurz zum Thema Markus Mann noch mal. Aus seiner Sicht könnte ich den Abgang zum KSC ganz klar verstehen. Also ich mein, er kann hier nicht ganz frei arbeiten. Es ist ganz klar, dass es diesen Stress zwischen TV und Kapitalseite gibt, dass er wenig Ressourcen hat zur Verfügung. Um dem RTL, Soap Opera, Vibe noch mal dazu zu steuern, lebt seine Familie tatsächlich bis heute noch in Süddeutschland. Das heißt, 500 Kilometer immer zwischen Familie und Kind pendeln, ist natürlich auch etwas, was man nach vier Jahren Arbeit auch irgendwann mal wieder einstellen möchte. Und dann wäre der KSC auch zwar sportlich, würde ich mal sagen, ein etwas schwächerer Verein in der Liga mit etwas weniger Ambitionen als wir. Natürlich ähnlich auf einer Augenhöhe. Aber ich könnte es aus einer Sicht völlig nachvollziehen. Und dann werden wir eben in der kommenden Saison mit einem mangelhaften Kader ohne Geschäftsführer und ohne Sportdirektor da. Und das ist halt eine Lage, in der sich kein Verein gerne befinden wird.
Ja, also für mich ist halt die Problematik, wenn es halt trotzdem so ist, dass sie sich jetzt einigen, dass es eben ein, dass man eben Sport oder Geschäftsführer Sport wird. Und es gibt da eben neben Geschäftsführer Finanzen. Aber du wirst ja irgendwann trotzdem, also wahrscheinlich diese Diskussionen immer wieder haben auch. Also und dieses, ich glaube, da bleibt einfach so ein Vakuum drin. Und klar, es gibt total Sinn, dass du da Parität hast. Aber es wird halt immer, also du wirst halt immer zwei Seiten haben, die im Endeffekt gegeneinander arbeiten. Und das, also ich glaube, da brauchen wir nicht lange diskutieren. Das ist halt für das Wohl von Hannover 96 nicht förderlich. Also ich meine, ich muss da auch sagen, aus diversen Gründen stehe ich da auf der, verstehe ich da den EV vollkommen. Also ich meine, du hast es sehr gut erläutert, Max, warum sie natürlich auch ihren Standpunkt verfolgen und warum sie natürlich auch eben ja eigentlich auch gerade auf diese Position des Geschäftsführers gehen und wie wichtig das für die ist. Es ist halt also ja, es ist halt ein Machtspiel, was halt aber einfach ein Enddatum haben muss, weil in zwei Wochen, also zwei Wochen, müssen diese Unterlagen vorliegen. Und du kannst danach auch nicht einfach, also ich glaube nicht, dass du da einmal gerade danach dann sagen kannst, okay wir berufen dich jetzt wieder ab und machen jetzt alles noch mal von vorne. Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass es rein rechtlich gesehen auch einfach mal so funktioniert. Also da muss ich auch ehrlich sagen, da enden auch immer meine Verständnisse für das deutsche Rechtssystem. Ich war froh, dass ich das verstanden habe.
Ich wollte auch kurz sagen, also meine Angaben sind doch ohne Gewähr. Also ich bin kein Jurist und ich hab's jetzt so interpretiert, wie ich das eben bei meinem Wissen nach machen kann. Am Ende vielleicht gibt es doch eine andere Möglichkeit, diese Weisungsklausel mit drin zu lassen. Aber mein Verständnis nach ist 50 plus 1 etwas, was immer eingehalten werden muss und zwar unter allen Umständen.
Ja vor allem gerade unter den speziellen Regeln, die natürlich jetzt auch eben immer wieder dann mit dem Kartellamt etc. vereinbart wurden. Also dass eben diese Ausnahmen nicht gelten oder bzw. also vor allem die Ausnahmen ja mehr untersucht werden sollen und eben nicht die Vereine, bei denen 50 plus 1 gilt oder halt an der Tagesordnung steht. Und ich glaube, wir könnten da tatsächlich auch noch, also ich glaube, das ist ja sogar dieses ganze Thematikgrund um diesen besagten Hannover-Vertrag, wo es halt immer wieder geht. Also ich glaube, ich habe da schon 80.000 mal irgendwelche Screenshots von gesehen und ich bin ganz ehrlich mit euch, ich verstehe 80% nicht von dem, was da drin steht. Also als das erstmal hieß so hier, ja der Satz, der ist der wichtige, habe ich ihn glaube ich achtmal gelesen, bis ich überhaupt verstanden habe, worum es geht. Also da muss ich auch einfach sagen, da ist bei mir mental, da setzt auch irgendwann einfach so eine Sperre ein, wo ich es nicht mehr verstehe. Aber ich glaube so oder so, ja wir werden da bestimmt in zwei Wochen sitze ich wieder hier und dann werden wir da bestimmt drüber reden, was halt das Aktuellste ist. Und ich glaube, man kann tatsächlich, also von daher entschuldigt bitte, dass es nicht noch ausführlicher geworden ist, aber es ist halt Tribünengespräch Material, mal wieder. Also es ist einfach diese ganzen juristischen Feinheiten rund um Hannover 96, die wirst du eben nicht in 20, 25 Minuten abatmen halten können. Und sonst schläft uns Matthias hier auch gleich ein.
Ja, vielleicht noch etwas zu Markus Mann sagen. Sorry. Ich meine, er hatte mal eine Spielervergangenheit auch in Darmstadt und ich glaube, er kam damals auch aus Karlsruhe und müsste da auch aus der Jugend hervorgegangen sein. Und ich war jetzt im Herbst in Karlsruhe beim Auswärtsspiel von Darmstadt. Und die haben da schon ein sehr gutes neues Zuhause dahin gezimmert, ein sehr stimmungsvolles Stadion. Ich glaube, da kann man sich als sportlicher Leiter auch durchaus wohl fühlen. Also es wird mich nicht überraschen, wenn er tatsächlich jetzt aus diesen Verwerfungen seine Konsequenzen zieht und vielleicht dabei es tatsächlich in Karlsruhe neu aufschlägt. Wäre möglich.
Obwohl man auch sagen muss, wenn man auch mal Karlsruhe die letzten Jahre verfolgt hat. Also der Haus auf Karlsruhe war auch ein Ding. Also ist jetzt nicht so, als ob Karlsruhe der Rüchse. Also als gäbe es da keine Aussichtsratquerelen, wenn ich mich da mal zurückerinnere. Gut. Es bleibt ja auch einfach brisant, Max. Denn am Wochenende steht das da wie gegen Braunschweig an.
Ohne Mittelfeld. Ohne Mittelfeld.
Und? Und ohne zumindestens Gäste, Fans, eh ne? Denn wir erinnern uns daran, Innenministerin Daniela Behrens hat sich ja, also erst hat sie sich ja glaube ich für einen Komplettausschluss von Gästefans ausgesprochen und man hat sich dann im Endeffekt auf einen Teilausschluss geeinigt. Das heißt, bei beiden Derbys waren nur 60% der Gästefans zugelassen und da sind es eben jetzt, in dem Fall hat es dann das letzte Wort eben die Polizeidirektion Hannover gehabt für das Spiel am Sonntag und die Ultras von Braunschweig werden eben nicht zum Derby anreisen, wie Hannover eben im Hinspiel auch schon nicht, gab auch wieder diese Demonstration. Also circa 500 Fans von Braunschweig sind vergangene Woche durch Hannover gezogen und eben bis zum Sportgericht dann am Ende unter dem Motto gegen Gästefaneinschränkungen, Fan-Kultur unverhandelbar. Da bin ich tatsächlich sehr gespannt, was da auch über diese Saison hinaus noch passieren wird. Sollten beide Vereine in einer Liga bleiben, das ist dann ja auch noch eine Sache, aber es ist eben, also Braunschweig jetzt zu Hause, dann Schalke auswärts, dann Magdeburg zu Hause. Das wird noch eine spannende Zeit und man könnte fast sagen, auch Braunschweig ist jetzt nicht in der besten Verfassung. Also vielleicht schafft man es zumindest, den Halbfans einen Derby zu schenken.
Ja, ich hoffe sehr. Ich hoffe sehr. Ohne Mittelfeld, also Enzo Leopold und Fabian Kunze fahren ja gelbgesperrt aus. Natürlich passend dann zum Derby immer. Surprise bei Fabian Kunze. Ja, große Überraschung bei Fabian Kunze, wobei er sich aber wirklich gebessert hat. Also jetzt erst fünf gelbe Karten, das war in der Vorsaison und in den Saisons auch davor deutlich, deutlich schlimmer. Also der hat sich auf jeden Fall aufgerafft. Nee, aber und es passt natürlich auch, dass wir genau zum wichtigsten Spiel der Saison dann so ein Chaos im EV und der Geschäftsführung haben. Und wenn es doch das Derby schief geht, dann sind die Fans alle begeistert am Ende.
Gut, Max, vielen Dank dafür. Matthias, es tut mir ein bisschen leid, dass du jetzt so doch lange warten musstest.
Alles gut. Also ich fühle mich bestärkt darin, Fan und Anhänger eines EVs zu sein.
Ja, das wär ich auch gerne. Das wär ich auch gerne.
Das ist doch schon mal schön. Aber dann lass uns auf, also vielen Dank wie gesagt an Max für die Ausführungen zu allen Themen reichen. Aber dann lass uns jetzt auf Darmstadt 98 schauen. Sie stehen auf Platz 13, haben 28 Punkte, 41 zu 41 Tore, 7 Siege, 7 Unentschieden und 10 Niederlagen. 2 Punkte Vorsprung auf die Hertha, 2 hinter Schalke und der Trainer, der ist Florian Krofeld. Der wurde gerade damals verpflichtet, als du dann damals im Rasenfunkzug Gast warst. Also da habe ich euch auch einmal nochmal die Folge verlinkt, wer nochmal interessiert, warum man eben auch sich damals für Florian Krofeld entschieden hat. Kann das gerne einfach nochmal nachhören. Da hat nämlich eben auch Matthias alles dazu erklärt. So am Wochenende gab es die 4 zu 1 Niederlage gegen Magdeburg nach 1-0 Führung. Also sehr tragische Geschichte ehrlich gesagt und eben auch nur 4 Punkte in der Rückrunde. 1 Siege gegen Schalke, ein Unentschieden gegen Düsseldorf, also gerade dieses Unentschieden gegen Düsseldorf sicherlich auch ein bisschen überraschend in gewissem Maße, aber eben auch 5 Niederlagen unter anderem gegen Braunschweig, die sicherlich einfach von der Konstellation mit so am meisten wehgetan hat. Eigentlich hat es ja unter Kohfeldt gar nicht so schlecht gestartet, Matthias. Also bis zur Winterpause gab es 6 Siege, unter anderem das 5 zu 1 gegen Kaiserslautern, wo man wahrscheinlich als Darmstein-Fan jetzt doch auch ein, zwei Mal doch die Augen reibt, wie das dann passiert ist. Nur zwei Niederlagen damals in der Liga. Man war zwischendurch sogar auf einem guten Weg zu einem einstelligen Tabellenplatz, hat da immer so knapp drunter gekratzt. Dazu eben der Achtelfinaleinzug im DFB-Pokal und eine sehr knappe Niederlage gegen die Bremer damals. Aber das Problem ist einfach, im neuen Jahr läuft es so gar nicht. Also man hat unter anderem eben mit der Niederlage gegen Regensburg gestartet, in Regensburg und was danach folgte, habe ich eben schon aufgezählt. Matthias, was ist da los?
Ja, wenn wir uns da so einen wirklichen Reim drauf machen könnten, dann wär es wahrscheinlich nicht so eingetreten. Es ist tatsächlich so, die von dir immer gerne erwähnten Serien, die leben wir genüsslich aus. Also erst sieben Spiele, nur ein Sieg, dann neun Spiele, keine Niederlage, 19 Punkte, da fielen mehrere 5 zu 1 Siege in diese Phase, also Köln, Fürth und Kaislautern eben. Und jetzt wieder acht Spiele in Serie, nur mit einem Sieg und den von dir genannten vier Punkten. Das hätte ich nach diesem 5 zu 1 vor Weihnachten gegen Kaislautern nie möglich gehalten, dass es tatsächlich jetzt so eine Vollbremsung gibt, weil das Team schien völlig gesettelt, die wissen, was sie tun, es gehen viele, viele Punkte auf. Sie haben sich quasi wirklich den Frust von der Seele geschossen. Also da waren diverse Spiele mit drei und mehr Toren dabei, die Pokalniederlage auch, die von dir erwähnte, quasi mit der letzten Aktion 0 zu 1 in Bremen verloren. Und Bremen war noch damals ein anderes Bremen, als es jetzt aktuell ist. Das heißt, das war für mich nicht absehbar, weil da schien so viel zu greifen und Trainerwechsel hat gegriffen. So die Altlasten des Bundesliga- Abstiegs waren irgendwie plötzlich aus den Klamotten. Aber deshalb ist es umso unerklärlicher, warum es jetzt wieder so ein Downfall ist, wie es im Roll ergibt. Dieses von dir auch angesprochene 1 zu 4 in Magdeburg war nach 55 Minuten nicht absehbar, weil sie hatten alles im Griff, meines Erachtens auch voll verdient geführt. Und ich hatte mich auch bei dem nur der FCM-Podcast rückversichert, dass ich da nicht so meine Ligenbrille exklusiv aufhabe, sondern dass das auch von denen so ein bisschen zugeordnet wird. Und da hatte der Thomas dankenswerterweise ein Feedback an mich gespielt, der auch meinte, bis 55 Minuten war das total stark von Darmstadt, hat auch defensiv stabil keinerlei wirklich nennenswerte Chancen von Magdeburg zugelassen. Und dann gibt es einen Gegentreffer und das Gebilde bricht in sich zusammen, was angesichts der Vorwoche auch nicht hätte sein dürfen, weil wir haben gegen Schalke auch ein sehr, sehr stabiles Spiel gezeigt, schnell zwei Tore gemacht, 2 zu 0 geführt und das Ergebnis dann wirklich gut verteidigt und immer wieder auch Chancen nach vorne gesehen genutzt oder eben nicht genutzt, aber zumindest gesucht. Das heißt, das Spiel entließ ein Positiv aus dem Böllenfalt-Tor und auch die ersten 55 Minuten Markt-Works sahen gut aus. Und dann aber so in sich zusammenzubrechen, das passt irgendwie nicht so ganz ins Bild. Also da scheint irgendwie die Mannschaft angegriffen zu sein, was ihr vielleicht mentales Korsett anbetrifft. Ich hatte jetzt, wie gesagt, auch mal mit dem Luca Marseilla vor kurzem sprechen können für das Stadion-Magazin. Der meint, es steckt immer wieder in so Kleinigkeiten, die Spiele zum Kippen bringen. Wir hatten ja nicht nur dieses. Also eigentlich waren alle in der Lage schmerzhaft. Jetzt in 2025 in Nürnberg 0 zu 1 gegen Ende, in Braunschweig 0 zu 1, dann auch zu Hause gegen Paderborn 1 zu 0. Also dreimal 1 zu 0. Das hätte er auch gut und gerne unentschieden oder mit ein bisschen Spielglück auch in unsere Richtung kippen können. Das meinte Luca Marseilla, dass du in solchen Spielen nicht ganz erklären kannst, warum es gekippt ist in die falsche Richtung. Und das habe ich tatsächlich schon von mehreren Profis gehört, immer wieder diese Kleinigkeiten, die Spiele entscheiden. Und ich dachte mir immer nur so, erzähl mir was vom Pferd, sind gemäß. Aber es scheint tatsächlich so zu sein, dass ein Profi, der auf dem Feld steht, ein anderes Bewusstsein von manchen Spielen hat, als man selber auf der Tribüne. Also diese kleinen Kleinigkeiten, die funktionieren nicht mehr. Dann hat sich irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch so was festgesetzt, was so ein bisschen der Fluch der guten Tat war. Man hat so nach zwei, drei Spielen mit Kohfeldt plötzlich einen Schalter umlegen können. Da ist mir dieses besagte Spiel in Karlsruhe Anfang Oktober sehr gut in Erinnerung. Da lag man zweimal zurück, kam zurück und zwar nicht nur kämpferisch, sondern auch spielerisch in einem lautstarken Stadion bei einem damaligen Spitzen-Team. Top 3, meine ich. Und da dachte ich, wow, da wächst was, da geht was zusammen. Und die Folgewochen haben es bewiesen. Aber das ist jetzt so schnell wieder in sich zusammen. Feld liegt womöglich auch an einigen Personalien. Also Liedberg war ja der Stürmer, der die meisten Tore zielt hat. Jetzt sind es glaube ich inzwischen 11. Aber der fiel einfach aus. Es nur an einer Person festzumachen, finde ich fast ein bisschen zu einfach. Aber dann kamen einfach noch andere Ausfälle, wie Klefisch, der in der Defensive schon alles zusammen rennt, was irgendwie zu stopfend ist an Löchern. Also manchmal ein bisschen zu übereifrig, aber dennoch glaube ich für die Mentalität eines Teams und so als Kleber. Innerhalb eines Teams nicht verkehrt. Und Kohfeldt musste auch in den ersten Spielen unter seiner Ägide, also bis zur Winterpause mehr oder minder nie wechseln. Also er hatte einmal zwei gewechselt, weil Bukocic seine erste Sperre hatte und noch ein anderer ausfiel. Aber ansonsten war es, die Mannschaft stellte sich von selbst auf und ich hab schon immer gedacht, mein Gott, irgendwann muss doch ein Team das System entschlüsseln, aber es passierte nie. Und jetzt in der Rückrunde ist es tatsächlich so, dass wir oftmals drei Neuzugänge in der Startelf hatten. Also Neuzugänge heißt vom vorherigen Spieltag nicht als Verpflichtungen per se und da scheint irgendwas dann doch ein bisschen nicht so ganz zu greifen. Und wer sicherlich in der Hinterrunde auch ein großer Faktor war, war Philipp Förster aus der Arbeitslosigkeit geholt, wenn man so will. Hatte in Bochum keinen Anschlussvertrag gekriegt, war auf dem Markt, aber offenbar hat er auf Erstliga-Angebote gewartet, die nicht kamen. Deshalb ging er dann im September zu uns und der war wirklich relativ schnell präsent. Und er hat ja manchmal so ein gewisses Fleck mal, könnte man meinen, wenn man zuschaut. Aber er hat dennoch dem Spiel immer wieder seinen Stempel aufgedrückt. Und auch bei uns im Podcast, als er vor Weihnachten nochmal aufgenommen hatte, hatte Daniel gemeint, für ihn ist der Spieler der Vorrunde, also noch vor Liebberg, weil er doch dem Team was gegeben hat, was davor nicht präsent war. Und der ist auch, wenn er gut drauf ist, ein Spieler, der doch Bundesliga-Format hat. Und in der Rückrunde konnte er es aber nie abrufen. Also er war quasi nicht präsent. Er war richtiggehend schlecht und jetzt auch seit mehreren Spielen erkrankt, nicht an Bord. Das heißt, da sieht man schon, dass wenn Förster nicht liefert und Liebberg verletzt ist und Kläfisch verletzt ist, dass dann doch Korsett-Stangen wegbrechen, die vielleicht wichtiger für das Gesamtkonstrukt sind, als man es sich zuvor hätte ausmalen können. Jetzt habe ich schon ein bisschen monologisiert, aber ich denke, da stecken einige Faktoren drin, die so ein bisschen versuchen, diese Negativserie zu erklären. Also viele kleine Mussecksteinchen, die so in die falsche Richtung gefallen sind. Und insofern ist glaube ich Kohfeldt zuletzt auch ein bisschen dünnhäutiger geworden, meine ich. Zumindest gab es nach dem Braunschweig-Spiel so Aussagen von ihm. Na ja, einer der Braunschweiger Spieler war zweimal mit Kopfverletzung auf dem Feld und hat sich behandelt lassen, rannte aber sofort wieder rein. Also so Zeitspiel-Vorwürfe schwangen da mit und jetzt auch gegen Magdeburg, ja wir hätten ja schon 4-0, 5-0 führen können. Das ist ein bisschen zu einseitig formuliert. Man hätte höher als 1-0 führen können, ja, aber 4-5-0 gewiss nicht. Das heißt, da schwangen doch deutlich Frust in den Nachspiel-Befragungen mit und das zeigt mir so ein bisschen, da ist vielleicht dann auch die Souveränität ein bisschen jetzt auch auf seiner Seite am Schwinden.
Ja, vor allem, also klar ist die eine Sache, wenn man 2-3-0 fielen muss und vielleicht dann hinterher nur unentschieden spielt, aber es ist dann das andere, also noch mal in Worten, 1 zu 4 verliert, nachdem man da 55 Minuten gute Spiele hingelegt hat. Das darf dir halt trotzdem so nicht passieren und ich hab also ich hab Konferenz geguckt und ich stand da immer mal so, was passiert dir denn jetzt? Also ich dachte, da muss ich doch eigentlich aufschwimmen. Vor allem ich fand's halt so, es ist ja das eine, wenn du sowieso aus so einer Negativspirale kommst, es ist also es ist nicht nur ein Klischee, es ist ja einfach so, du kannst es ja immer wieder beobachten. Für Teams, die oben sind, denen fällt es dann einfacher, da vielleicht auch rauszukommen, so ein Spiel zu drehen, da das Selbstbewusstsein rauszuziehen. Und wenn du eher unten drinstehst und vielleicht so ein bisschen die Erfolgserlebnisse wieder ausbleiben, dann ist es halt schwieriger, weil sobald du dann halt ein Gegentor kassierst, dann verselbstständigt sich das Ganze und dann kriegst du halt, dann brichst du halt ein bisschen auseinander, weil du eigentlich sagst, hey, wir haben doch eigentlich bis hier ein gutes Spiel gemacht. Warum kriegen wir den Ertrag nicht daraus? Aber was ich halt, also es ist halt doppelt bitter, weil du eigentlich eben genau diese Serie wieder starten könntest, weil du davor ja zwei Null gegen Schalke gewonnen hast. Und eigentlich dachte ich so, ja, okay, eben auch das, die ersten 55 Minuten, so ey, eigentlich bist du jetzt voll auf der guten Seite und hast eigentlich dieses Momentum. Du bist dann zusammengebrochen. Und ich glaube, also ich hab's eben gesagt, 41 zu 41 Tore, da spiegelt das eigentlich auch ganz gut wider, weil die Offensive, die liegt bei Darmstadt ganz klar über dem Liga-Durchschnitt. Also ich hab's mal ausgerechnet, die liegt immer so 36,6, wo halt zum Beispiel Hannover deutlich drunter ist. Aber die Defensive, die ist halt unterm Durchschnitt eben gleichzeitig, logischerweise auch bei der gleichen Langzeit von Toren. Und da ist halt eben die XG, also die man geschossen hat, die passen eigentlich. Also ich glaube, da liegt ein Tor dazwischen im Endeffekt. Das ist nicht so der große Unterschied. Das liegt schon relativ bei... Also da ist man eigentlich auf seinem Soll, sag ich mal. Da gibt es jetzt keine großen Ausreißer nach oben oder nach unten. Gleicht sich natürlich in so einer Saison auch irgendwann mal aus. Aber gleichzeitig hat man eigentlich acht Tore ungefähr zu viel kassiert.
Ja, das ist wirklich ein springender Punkt.
Und das sind Unterschiede, ne?
Also es gab erst zwei zu null Spiele diese Saison. Einmal zu Hause gegen Münster und einmal jetzt gegen Schalke eben. Und das bedeutet, man hat in 22 Spielen das nicht verstanden, sein Tor ausreichend abzusichern. Und das wirkt jetzt eigentlich auch, wenn man die Spiele verfolgt, nicht irgendwie wie ein Hühnerhaufen da hinten. Das wirkt schon relativ stabil. Vukotic hat sich als Neuzugang nahtlos eingefügt in das Team und ist für mich auch noch eher der Abwehrchef in der Viererkette als jetzt Clemens Riegel, der als Kapitän auch erst 21 ist, aber auch jetzt gegen Magdeburg mutmaßlich gefehlt hat in diesem Abwehrverbund. Aber dennoch, wir schaffens einfach nicht oder die Lilien schaffens einfach nicht die Null zu halten. Und das ist natürlich schon schwer, wenn du nicht davon ausgehen kannst, ein Tor reicht dir um Sieg zu erringen, sondern du musst eigentlich schon mehr draufsatteln, dann wirds schwer. Und beispielhaft sind für mich zwei Gegentore der jüngsten Vergangenheit, nämlich dieses 0 zu 1 in Braunschweig, das dann auch gleichzeitig das Endergebnis war und jetzt eben das 1 zu 1 in Magdeburg. Das waren nahezu Kopien. Also du hattest lange Sololäufe, einmal von Tempelmann, der dann glücklicherweise vor dem 16. noch mal in den Ball kommt und dann vollendet. Und jetzt eben Burcu, der auch in der eigenen Hälfte startet und bis zum 16. durchmarschieren kann. Das hätte fünf Spieler geben können, die ihn hätten stoppen können. Also das bedeutet, du hast auch eine fehlende Abgezocktheit in diesen beiden Fällen, die so wie das Messer durch die Butter fahren zu lassen, ist wirklich unverständlich. Da muss man auch mal in Foul ziehen und jetzt niemanden umhauen, aber einfach am Trikot ziehen oder sonst was, damit es an der Stelle dann halt ein taktisches Foul ist. Aber diese beiden Soli waren einfach ärgerlich, weil es in beiden Fällen die Niederlage eingeleitet hat. Und ja, das ist schon schwer zu verknusen, wenn es dann gar zu einfach geht.
Vielleicht nicht. Also sorry, sag gerne mal.
Ja, willst du aber den Vorwurf der Kaderplanung geben? Weil korrigiere ich gerne, wenn ich falsch liege. Aber ich glaube, ihr habt doch mit Riedel, Magliza und Vukotic eigentlich gar keine etatmäßigen Innenverteidiger mehr, oder? Und ich finde ja, dass Magliza und Vukotic jetzt keine Verteidiger sind, mit der man jetzt defensiv Höheres erreicht, vor allem wenn man sich die physischen Defizite anguckt und so. Und ich glaube, ich finde es persönlich fahrlässig, so mit nur drei Verteidigern zu planen.
Ja, also es gab sogar unser Lieberknecht, als man die Saison gestartet ist, das plante man mit einer Dreier-, Fünferkette, das heißt dann nominell eher Dreienverteidiger. Damals gab es noch Klaus Gersula. Andy Müller hat jetzt auch die Innenposition in einer Dreierkette übernommen, also nicht mehr im defensiven Mittelfeld gegen Magdeburg, sondern weiter hinten angesiedelt. Das hat insofern ganz gut geklappt, weil man lange Zeit außen doppeln konnte und damit Magdeburg gar nicht so richtig ins letzte Drittel kommen ließ. Aber wir haben auch noch jemanden wie Christoph Zimmermann, der leider dauerverletzt ist und gar nicht mehr eine Rolle spielt, der wohl, liest man mit auslaufendem Vertrag wohl auch nicht mehr weiter bei den Lilien dann sein wird im neuen Jahr oder er ist jetzt auch nicht mehr der Allerjüngste, keine Ahnung, was da seine persönlichen Ziele sind. Aber was will ich sagen, also wir hatten schon zu Saisonbeginn die berechtigte Hoffnung mit Yasula Zimmermann und eventuell auch mit einem Andy Müller in der Innenverteidigung auflaufen zu können. Gleichwohl ist Andy Müller für mich kein per se Innenverteidiger, schon allein von der Körpergröße nicht. Und jetzt haben wir in der Winterpause noch Dreskovic geholt, ein Montenegriner, der in Ungarn gespielt hat, da nach den Informationen, die mir vorliegen, durchaus eine gute Rolle spielte im Ranking der Innenverteidiger liegweit. Aber Ungarn-Asteliga ist jetzt sicherlich noch mal ein anderer Schnack. Und er hat zum Beispiel jetzt auch nicht den Vortritt vor Magliza erhalten in Magdeburg. Und Magliza ist ein Linksfuß. Also der hat auch mir gegenüber in Interviews schon gesagt, wenn er die Möglichkeit hat, mit links oder rechts zu spielen, dann macht das mit links. Und jetzt war halt der rechte Innenverteidiger in der Dreierkette auch nicht so geschickt. Und er ist natürlich jetzt auch nicht in der Spielpraxis. Also hat man ihm vielleicht auch nicht so gut getan, in so ein Spiel dann reingeworfen zu werden. Gleichwohl erste Halbzeit hätte ich ihm da keine Schuld zugesprochen an irgendwas. Aber zweite Halbzeit, wenn drei Tore über deine Seite fallen, im Verbunden mit Lopez, schwierig. Also um deine Frage aufzugreifen, ich glaube, kadertechnisch war das jetzt nicht fahrlässig, was man gemacht hat, aber es hat sich durch gewisse Ausfälle dann doch ein bisschen zugespitzt. Und da man aber auf Viererkette wiederum umgestellt hat, glaube ich, ist ohne jetzt Dreskovic Leistungen kennen zu können, doch zumindest so, dass ich jetzt nicht da die sportliche Verantwortlichkeit anzählen würde. Also ich denke, da sehe ich jetzt nicht den wirklich wunden Punkt. Man hatte natürlich vor der Saison noch Paul Will geholt für die sechste Position im Tandem mit Klefisch wäre das glaube ich sehr vielversprechend gewesen. Klefisch eher der Dauerläufer und eher robustere Spieler, der dazwischen fegt und Paul Will als sehr feiner Spielmacher von hinten raus. Das hätte für mich gut funktionieren können, aber gleichwohl kannst du dich natürlich nie von Verletzungen freisprechen. Nur wahrscheinlich denkt ein Kaderplaner oder auch ein Trainer eher so von seiner ersten Elf her, dass er sagt, okay um die herum versuche ich was aufzubauen und dann habe ich noch ein paar, die hinten dran als Backup sind, wie Andi Müller, wie Papella, aber die mussten jetzt leider, was heißt leider, die durften sich jetzt beweisen, die sind im Endeffekt die Doppel-Sechs-Zeit seit längerem und machen es jetzt nicht per se schlecht, aber haben jetzt auch nicht vielleicht diese Körperlichkeit wie ein Kläfisch oder andere. Also eher kleinere, durchaus auch spielstärkere Sechser, aber keine, die jetzt wahrscheinlich Ligaspitze sind.
Ich musste ein bisschen lachen, als du eben meintest, auch einfach mal im Mittelfeld das Foul ziehen, vielleicht dann nicht direkt für Fabian Nürnberger.
Ja, total total dämlich. Also da gab es auch genug Lilen-Fans, mit denen ich mich unterhalten hat, für alle, die es nicht vor Augen haben. Also wir gegen Elbersbergen, absolutes Frustfoul in Verbindung mit Körperverletzung an Elias Baum. Also das war wirklich fast schon mit Ansage, weil nach dem 3 zu 0 kam die Mannschaft zusammen, um sich mal auf dem Feld zu sammeln und Nürnberger ist nur ein Stück weit hingegangen, dann wird er umgedreht, also hat sich da gar nicht in den Kreis integriert und wenig später wird er von Baum überlaufen oder ausgetribbelt und er haut ihm ohne Chance auf den Ball mit voller Wucht gegen das Knie. Also rot mit Ansage und dann auch noch Handgreiflichkeit anzunehmen, sag ich mal und auszuteilen. Doppeldeemlich 8 Spiele Spereger hab ich auch schon lang nicht mehr gehört. Gleichwohl 3 auf Bewährung, das heißt 2 Spiele dürfte er noch fehlen, dann ist er wieder da. Ja, also bei manchen Lidenfans hat er eher so ein bisschen den Arroganzfaktor, der so ein bisschen jetzt als Nationalspieler für Bulgarien wohl auch da eine gewisse Arroganz ausstrahlt. Das kann ich jetzt gar nicht so sagen. Muss ich aus meiner Warte heraus berichten. Ich finde, er hat sich mit der Außenverteidigerposition besser angefreundet als zu Erstliga-Zeiten. Also er spielt die linke Außenbahn im Vierer-Verbund und hat das solide gespielt, finde ich. Er hat gleich wohl auch immer so ein paar Leichtsensaktionen dabei, bevorzugt den Ball hinterm Standbein rumlegen, um dann irgendwie anderswo aufzudrehen. Das geht oft genug auf, aber manchmal denke ich mir auch, lasst mir lieber den Move und spiel seriös. Aber ja, er fehlt uns jetzt an der Stelle auch. Wohingegen ist Bueno, der von Dortmund 2 auf der Drittlassigkeit kam, auch durchaus gutmacht. Also wir haben jetzt Spieler, die nicht die Bäume ausreißen, aber die jetzt auch kein absolutes Downgrade darstellen, finde ich.
Zwei Punkte an der Stelle, weil du eben einmal jetzt öfter schon die Thematik der Fans angesprochen hast. Wie ist da denn die Stimmung? Also ich habe schon ab und zu, ich glaube auch gerade noch dem Elversberg-Spiel, dann schon ein, zwei Mal so ein bisschen Pfiffe gehört. Aber wie ist denn generell die Stimmung so im Stadion oder beziehungsweise generell bei den Fans?
Ja, da kann ich das letzte Spiel in Erinnerung rufen. Das war eben das Heimspiel gegen Schalke und da war sofort von Anfang an die Bande zwischen Mannschaft und Fans gesucht und gefunden. Also es gab ein Transparent, es gab Aufmutterungsrufe, es gab die Mannschaft, die vor dem Spiel bewusst noch mal zu den Fans mehr gegangen ist, als es davor gepflegt hatten. Also da war schon der Wille da, gemeinsam an einem Strang zu ziehen und das hat natürlich mit den zwei schnellen Toren dann total gefruchtet. Also die Stimmung da war hervorragend, das war auch Sonnenschein, wie es am Böllentoren natürlich auch lietechnisch sehr gerne gesehen wird. Und dann gab es ja noch dieses Motto Shirt, Demokratiewählen auf dem Trikot, also dieses Sondershirt, was auch ein Großteil meines Erachtens der Fans skutiert hat, dass das so noch mal am Tag der Bundestagswahl auf der Brust getragen wurde. Also da war viel angerichtet und es war von Anfang an ein enges Band zu verspüren. Und etwas wäre klar, war natürlich ernüchternd, das so zu sehen, so hergespielt zu werden im eigenen Stadion. Da gab es vereinzelt Pfeffer, aber jetzt nichts, was irgendwie hätte ins Wanken bringen können. Und natürlich davon jetzt noch so spielen, wie in Magdeburg nicht jetzt die sozialen Medien aufrufen oder die Foren durchs Kollen, da kriegt man schlechte Laune garantiert. Aber ich erlebe so, dass schon jetzt die Wahrnehmung da ist, wir müssen nach hinten gucken, alles andere wäre fahrlässig und unruhig wird es noch nicht, aber man ist so eine Hab-Acht-Stellung. Also ich sag mal, wenn jetzt die nächsten Spiele auch in die Binsen gehen, dann wird es schon ungemütlicher. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, was das dann für Konsequenzen hat, weil wie ich eingangs sagte, ich glaube, die Mannschaft ist selber gerade so ein bisschen am Struggeln, auch mental, um da wieder in die Spur zu kommen. So nach dem Motto, anfänglich erst mal ins Hintertreffen geraten, dann lief vieles wie von allein. Und jetzt weiß man wieder nicht so richtig, welchen Gang man einlegen muss. Und ich bin der Meinung, die Mannschaft ist gut genug, um sich da hinten raushalten zu können. Das hat sich oft genug gezeigt. Wenn allerdings der Kopf die Oberhand gewinnt, dann wäre ich mir gar nicht so sicher, dass da nicht doch wir bis zum Schluss zittern müssen. Aber im Moment ist die so eine gespannte Erwartungshaltung. Wo geht es denn jetzt wirklich hin? Was können wir erwarten? Aber noch nicht die größte Unruhe. Und ich glaube auch, dass Kofeld nicht hinterfragt wird. Hier in Darmstadt, das hatte ich damals auch gesagt, ist man es gewohnt, dass das Präsidium an dem Trainer festhält. Also entlassen wurde hier schon lange keiner mehr. Es wurden eher Trainer dann weggekauft oder man hat sich auf keine Vertragsverlängerung geeinigt. Sozusagen wie damals bei Kramotz. Also ich denke, da hat Kofeld schon dieses Umfeld hier, wo in aller Ruhe und Nüchternheit gearbeitet wird und nicht jetzt populistisch irgendwas vom Zaun gebrochen wird und dann in einer Entlassung mündet. Deshalb tut ihm das schon gut und er hat sich auch gleich dem Verein committed, weil ich glaube, das war das, was er gesucht hat. Ein ruhiges Umfeld, ein kleineres Umfeld, kein medial im Blickpunkt stehendes Umfeld. Hat auch gesagt, er zieht hierher mit seiner Familie, was ich mir schon so dachte, vielleicht dann auch etwas riskant, aber andererseits tut es ihm vielleicht auch gut, wenn er die Familie an seiner Seite weiß. Und deshalb würde ich es ihm schon wünschen, dass er hier dann auch die Früchte erntet, weil bei uns Lillienfans war es so wie auch landläufig. Man hat so sich gedacht, Kohfeldt, das ist ja eher so die letzte Patrone, sowohl für ihn als auch vielleicht für die Lillien mit einem missratenen Saisonstart. Aber er hat sich dann gleich mal gezeigt, was er im Stande ist zu bewirken. Und dann wurde ja auch immer landauf, landab diese Kohfeldtabelle aufgerufen. Darmstadt ja eher Aufstiegsaspirant, wenn sie nicht den schlechten Saisonstart gehabt hätten. Und jetzt wird es ihm wieder vor die Füße gelegt, guck dir mal jetzt die Kohfeldtabelle an. Aber er hat gleich wohl schon im November auf die Bremse getreten. Also medial war ihm das too much. Er hat gleich wohl gesagt, hier, mir wär's lieber, er würde so ein bisschen die Grautöne betrachten und nicht mal himmelhoch heraufzend und dann wieder zu Tode betrübt. Und er ist nicht derjenige, der alleine den Erfolg zu verantworten hat damals, sondern es war das Team in erster Linie und das Team hinter dem Team. Und er ist ein Teil dieses Teams hinter dem Team, aber nicht derjenige, der alleine dafür verantwortlich ist. Und der Staff hinter dem Team ist mittlerweile auch mit zehn Coaches bestückt, also schon sehr namhaft mit Athletiktrainer, mit Reha-Trainer oder sowas. Das heißt, da ist schon eine Menge Substanz da. Und er hat wirklich wahrscheinlich auch angesichts seiner eigenen Vita damals gesagt, halt mal den Ball flach. Und ich glaube, das kann man ihm auch zugute halten, dass er damals den Hype-Train nicht befeuert hat, sondern schon versucht hat, gegenzusteuern.
Ja, noch zwei letzte Anmerkungen bzw. eine Anmerkung. Und dann noch eine ganz kurze, abschließende Frage. Einmal, ich glaube, es ist gar nicht so schlecht, dass man jetzt gegen Karlsruhe und Köln spielt. Weil ich finde, man hat schon eben das Gefühl gehabt, wir haben eben drüber gesprochen, vielleicht ist es fast besser, gegen Vereine zu spielen, die selber auch ein bisschen mehr wissen, was sie mit dem Ball anfangen wollen. Also die Aussteiger machen das auch alle berechtigterweise so, aber einfach oder die da unten drin stehen. Und vielleicht liegt es ja da im Stadt fast. Also zum Beispiel das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf eben als als Anhaltspunkt zu nehmen, wo man ja zumindest das Unentschieden spielen konnte. Und gut, danach kommt ein Ulm. Also da ist dann halt schon klar, da sind halt drei Punkte alternativ los, weil einfach aufgrund der Tabellensituation und generell einfach wegen der Lage. Ich glaube, das ist relativ klar. Eine letzte Frage noch, weil wir jetzt ebenso viel über die ganzen Vereinsstrukturen bei Hannover geredet haben. Du hast gesagt, du bist sehr glücklich, dass du Fan eines EVs bist quasi oder Vereinen mit EV-Struktur. Wie sieht es denn einfach, ich weiß, ein bisschen gemein, aber einmal zusammengefasst vielleicht auch finanziell aus bei Darmstadt 98. Und gibt es da sonst auch, ich sag mal, Vereinsstruktur mäßig irgendwelche Probleme momentan?
Ja, da bin ich jetzt tatsächlich gar nicht so tief drin, weil es keine Anlässe gibt, sich damit zu beschäftigen, wie jetzt im Falle von Hannover. Genau, auch gut. Natürlich hat jeder, der das Böllnfalltor-Stadion von früher kannte und heute wieder da ist, sieht es mit eigenen Augen, hier ist was getan worden. Hier wurde viel in Infrastruktur investiert. Das will gleichwohl natürlich dann auch abgebaut werden, die Kosten, die da anfielen. Da hat das letzte Jahr Bundesliga sicherlich nicht schlecht getan. Und ich meine mich noch zu erinnern, dass es bei der Jahreshauptversammlung auch so ein Schad gab, dass man doch ganz gut aus der Bundesliga rausgegangen ist, weil man auch kaum Prämien zahlen musste. Also, insofern. Voll gut. Genau. Man hat wenig von Spielers Seite dafür getan, Gelder zusätzlich zu erlangen und damit den Verein abzuziehen. Ja, das war jetzt kleiner Side-Effekt. Also ich denke, man darf die Darmstädter wahrscheinlich als einen der gesünderen Vereine finanztechnisch betrachten. Und man hat hier auch nie sonderliche Hara-Kiri-Aktion gemacht. Also man hat jetzt auch schon länger keine Trainer mehr auf der Payroll, die keine Trainer sind. Da gab es noch eine Phase. Da hatten wir drei zeitgleich auf der Payroll, weil Thorsten Fringsten nach einem halben Jahr gesagt hat, ich mach mal zweieinhalb Jahre keinen neuen Job. Und dann ging er nach Mappen und war es dann wenige Monate später auch schon nicht mehr. Mit Lieberknechts hat man sich auf eine Vertragsauflösung geeinigt. Also insofern glaube ich, da droht uns jetzt wenig ungemacht. Man hat zwar sicherlich Gelder in die Hand genommen für Liedberg oder auch für Corridor, der auch eine feste Säule ist. Aber man hat auch wiederum Gelder eingenommen durch Clara und durch Melem-Verkäufe nach England. Da wurde auch gutes Geld gezahlt. Also alles in allem, ich glaube, finanziell müssen wir uns jetzt nicht so sehr Sorgen machen um die Lilien. Da ist alles im Fluss. Und wie gesagt, man wirtschaftet hier auch sehr mit Augenmaß nach wie vor, weil das Presidium, das jetzt in Amt und Würden ist, in großen Teilen immer noch auch schon zu Insolvenzzeiten an Bord war. Also da ist eine große Kontinuität. Da wird immer gerne gesagt, wir wissen, wo wir herkommen. Können viele Fans schon nicht mehr so hören, aber das ist dennoch gelebt. Also man hat schlechte Zeiten an eigenen Bleib verspürt und kann daraus jetzt immer noch seine Schlüsse ziehen. Und wir haben ein neues Stadion. Die Mannschaft ist jetzt soweit auch nicht außer Konkurrenz unterwegs, sondern entpuppt sich immer wieder als Leistung stark. Und ich denke jetzt finanziell soweiten meines Erachtens, ohne jetzt zu tief drin zu sein, doch durchaus einen Haken zu setzen. Und die nächsten Aufgaben hast du schon genannt. Also mit Teams, die spielen wollen, mit denen hat man sich in der Hinrunde sehr leicht getan oder konnte die gut bespielen. Gegen die Anderdogs hatte man Probleme. Also man hat in Regensburg verloren, man hat jetzt auch in Braunschweig verloren. Man hat auch in Regen gegen Ulm und Münster nur Unschienen gespielt. Also so ein Selbstläufer ist das nicht. Ich glaube, in Münster und in Ulm nicht zu verlieren in der Rückrunde wäre schon fast ein Teil Erfolg. Aber mal schauen, Karlsruhe und Köln hast du gesagt. Da bin ich sehr gespannt, ob es eher so.
Da könnt ihr auch gerne gewinnen gegen die.
Hätte ich nichts dagegen.
Ich werde euch auf jeden Fall die Daumen drücken gegen Karlsruhe und Köln. Das würde mich sehr freuen, wenn ihr da wieder zusieht.
Ich werde es weiterreichen.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, worüber wir reden, wenn ich hier in zwei Wochen wieder sitze und mal schauen, wie das wie das geklappt hat mit den Vorhersagen. Also das ist ja wirklich nicht alle zwei Wochen kannst du hier gefühlt. Sitze ich alle zwei Wochen und könnte alle Leute wieder direkt neu einladen, über mit denen ich noch vor drei, vier Wochen. Also weil es einfach immer, es ist einfach, es ist crazy. Ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich da und das wiederholen sich auch gefühlt immer alle Gästinnen. Aber es ist ja auch schön, dass wir uns bei sowas alle einig sind, dass diese Liga einfach auch unberechenbar ist und das ja, es macht halt auch am Ende, also für mich macht Spaß. Ich bin halt da emotional gar nicht mal so involviert, noch, haha. Aber deshalb, nein, es ist natürlich, ich kann ehrlich gesagt auch die ganzen Witze rund um den HSV nicht mehr hören und so und auch immer das dann immer so, ja hier viel Spaß mit Elvesberg und Paderborn, erste Bundesliga und so. Ich mein, ja, es ist halt auch irgendwann, muss man dann auch mal anerkennen, wenn andere Vereine gute Arbeit leisten. Lange bleiben sie da ja meistens, trotzdem nicht, das ist einfach so. Aber trotzdem ist das ja irgendwie kein böser Winde des Fußballgottes, sondern da haben dann vielleicht auch einige Vereine einfach geschlafen. So ungern man das vielleicht auch gerne mal hören möchte, aber das ist einfach so. Und damit muss man dann noch irgendwie klarkommen, weil es gibt ja meistens dann noch so 16 andere Vereine, die dieser Aufsteiger auch verhindern könnten, wenn sie wollen. Und ja, vielleicht werde ich da auch irgendwann langsam zu zynisch für, aber irgendwann kann ich diese, also habe ich das Gefühl, wir machen seit fünf Jahren die gleichen Witze und es ist immer nicht mehr lustig. Aber gut, wir hören jetzt auf mit Witzen, weil es jetzt schlussendlich lustig ist. Ich bedanke mich ganz, ganz herzlich bei dieser Runde. Vielen, vielen Dank an Max für dein Debüt im Rasenfunk. Du hast es ganz hervorragend gemacht, wie ich finde. Vielen Dank für all deine Ausführungen.
Vielen Dank.
Und natürlich auch großes Dankeschön an Matthias, der uns mal wieder Darmstadt 98 erklärt hat. Und auch da bestimmt uns noch eine Stunde oder anderthalb Stunden mehr was dazu erzählen könnte. Aber irgendwann müssen wir jetzt Schluss machen. Aber vielen Dank, Matthias, dass du auch da mit dabei warst.
Ganz lieben Dank.
Ja, und dann wie gesagt von mir auch ein herzliches Danke in die Runde fürs Zuhören. Wie gesagt, erinnert euch noch mal an die ganze Thematik rund um die Umstellung ab 19. März. Da bitte registrieren, in die Show notes gucken oder euch einfach nochmal den Anfang dieser Folge anzuhören, wenn ihr schon wieder vergessen habt, worum es da geht. Ihr werdet in den nächsten Wochen dazu noch informiert. Wir hören uns in zwei Wochen wieder. Macht's gut. Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.